all right team
um so uh welcome to the full council
meeting of the 22nd of August and we're
an hour earlier
than usual so nice to see everybody here
pool team I can't remember the last time
we had it here
there must be something on the Food Lion
Ellen that you're here
you do you worship
oh you rip me all right just works for a
few things that open up as we open up
the meeting we're obviously live
streaming so welcome to those that are
watching on live stream welcome to
Michael he's here today
um
uh obviously no apologies and no
Declarations of Interest unless somebody
wants to put their hand up
you telling us I think Steve that we
should know about
nothing comes out yeah or about your
singing voice over the weekend oh did
you stay for the singing oh so yeah oh
yeah I was
going to be honest so hope you enjoyed
it yeah
you made me slightly nervous yeah you
would
did you get did you get Shanghai for
that what's that did you get Shanghai
for singing did you know you were going
to sing
um we had a quick a quick run through
yes yeah very good okay very fast so
we've got nothing in the public forum
today and we have one major Live Aid on
that comes in which is the amendment to
the government statement which is in the
tail end of the agenda if somebody would
like to move that it comes in
I'll move that way thank you Leslie and
Darren
and all those in favor
aye Kerry
um so we've got a series of minutes that
we need to initially just work our way
through
um so the first one on the agenda is the
minutes of the meeting of Great South
jet joint shareholders and all we're
doing is acknowledging that's incoming
given that I'm the only one that was on
um on the on that group that came
through so something you'd like to move
that we accept those Barry thank you
Leslie any discussion or any issues
around that
being that all those in favor of
receiving those hi Gary thank you and
the minutes of the council meeting held
on the 18th of July
thank you
any discussion around those
there being none all those of favor I
carry well it's a meeting of risk and
Assurance committee held on the 18th of
July I'll move that way they do
and just as an issue for me
um and and that report does make
reference on page 28 of our board books
to a review of performance of the
committee which is the risk and
Assurance committee was withdrawn
and my memory is fading a little bit I
can't quite understand uh why we were
through there if somebody can help any
recall listen yeah yeah okay Mr Dave's
going to answer that one yeah he is yes
thank you that was a very swiftly passed
yeah through yourself mayor
um the chair of the committee didn't
have time to prepare the report in the
timeline and requested that we have it
deferred until the next meeting so he
plans on bringing that to the next
meeting okay yeah because that was one
of the issues that we've collectively
raised before was the volume of work
that was going through that committee
was quite large
whether there was some way that we could
shorten that list of work down a little
bit so that's fine any other questions
in relation to those minutes
all right there being none all those a
favor hi carried
oh sorry my mistake there was a
recommendation from the risk Insurance
committee
that is part of my moving yeah thank you
Leslie
not you this time Darren no it was crap
yeah yep there is one recommendation
isn't it
proposal and fees and for those that
were there at the time we had quite a
bit of discussion about those
um and certainly uh I guess the eye
watering amount that those fees have
gone up to now
and we'll potentially track up again in
the future so quite a bit of discussion
with the orders you can see Patricia at
the background smiling there
um so somebody would like to uh quite
happy to move those two we'll move those
recommendations as well
thank you Leslie um all those are flavor
I carried
okay uh for the minutes of the
infrastructure committee held on the 1st
of August yeah I'll move that right
thank you
see yeah Peter thank you
um any discussion relations over minutes
yeah being none all those in favor
aye Gary minutes of the meeting of the
bluff community board held on the
seventh divorce
thank you and Barry uh any discussion in
relation to those I'll just disappointed
yep sorry you go I'll just make a
comment about it was really good to have
Southport at that meeting okay and they
gave us a very thorough update
um which is included in the minute it's
just around where the port's at and it
was an opportunity also for the
community to engage and I think it's
been a wee while since I've been there
so yeah I think it's worth noting that
in Southport you know I've really
reached out and engaged with the
community again which is great so sure I
noticed on the minute so you did it did
make mention of the oyster festivals
well attended
and unless I've missed something I
wasn't quite sure what that meant oh we
had a great time
so the community board had a good feed
of voices is that what you're saying
is that a typo or do they actually have
an awesome Festival they haven't
no I didn't think so no
thank you Mr Mayor we all note that and
get it corrected at the time it goes to
the uh Bluff community board for
confirmation yeah I thought I thought
I'd missed on something you know Barry
you heard something oh sorry Peter yeah
thank you sorry yeah there was uh one
admission there for the attendees uh
Lindsay beer for the bluff promotions
did attend that meeting and it's
mentioned later on where you made a
report so his name is not on the list
okay so just something mine of it yeah
thank you
okay uh any further discussion on those
mats
that being none all those in favor
aye
minutes on the community wellbeing
committee held on the 8th of August
remember if they received thanks Darren
trash thank you any discussion around
those
jobs sure my name mentioned a couple of
times in there and it's uh Stewart is
spelled the wrong way yeah yep sound a
few times I was going to raise that
before Leslie jumped the gun and beat me
to it
um but the yeah they're spelled wrong
way now our apologies for that counselor
we will correct that um as I'm sure you
appreciate malavika has been to
confident to my the rest of my team at
getting used to
life in our committee so my apologies
okay oh sorry correct yes it just we had
a good discussion around the trees
um and I think Barry raised it
particularly around the
um the miter 10 thing and driving down
there we were lately and I think it was
a really valid point that we need to
lean into a bit
more around just the the danger those
trees potentially present to our
community
um and you know if we're in very drawing
weather and then we get a wet period it
softens the ground and yep you know
significant risk on the other side of
that road and through that road as a
main arterial route so
I think that should be raised through
important risk potentially or somewhere
working probably Michael's got his ear
to the issue so Michael tomorrow sure
yeah yeah because we were actually just
discussing discussing Master plans and
management plans but it was noted by the
staff and they will come back to us with
an update on what's going on with the
trees so that should be at the next
hopefully the next community
come through your committee yeah yeah
whatever we're calling it this week yeah
until I change it cool
yeah very first yeah there's also a
group of trees uh on gong and
Queens Drive
some like a couple of them are already
the same town belt yeah yeah you're
already leaning over a company
well it'll be a bit obvious if it came
down on Tom's truck again wouldn't it
not that much
[Laughter]
Barry mentioned what I was going to
mention I mentioned about Dawn and
Queens Drive a couple of uh people that
walk there
the dogs around there they may comment
to me about it so I said that we are
well aware of that yeah so thank you
so any further discussion I'm sorry
yourself chair um just want to highlight
we we have got all of those trees within
the um dangerous trees plan
um they are on the list to be
investigated and brought back through
that committee so they are on the list
any further discussion
no being none all those in favor
I caring
so we've got the minutes of the finance
and project committee held on the 15th
of August
we have a recommendation there as well
so that was in relation to a draft risk
graph Financial Risk Management policy
or adoption of council as presented
yeah
okay without any discussion around that
there being none
I'm sorry sorry ring
uh thank you chair look um Justin uh
paragraph five that refers at the bottom
um to a point I made about CCTV whether
it should be on the dashboard for
projects and the notation there was that
um
we may need additional dashboards it's
one of these key projects so I just
wonder where we are going with that will
that will that become a dashboard item
rather than sitting in there sort of
vowels of infrastructure
all right the microwave look at that
throw yourself to you
um look I can confirm we are working on
a a full project dashboard to go back
through finance and projects we
currently only have the Strategic
projects that go through our project
management office so they have
much those are the roadmap projects
there are a few exceptions to that which
have been added to their bandwidth but
however the CCTV for an example was like
a number of projects is very interesting
for a council perspective and we want to
get that up but we're working on getting
you a full Capital project list so you
can actually see them all not in just
one in isolation going forward so would
we see that say in a month's time on the
next oh sorry every two months sorry for
that one
about October or something yeah I
highlighted at the last we've got a
resource Gap in that that spot we're
trying to work through that
um I will work with the team to see if
there's an option of getting you a list
to the next meeting but so the reason I
raise this is that it's not just pipes
and and footpaths and start bits there's
a lot of public interest in this and so
um it shows yeah yeah the dashboard
thing is actually quite good because as
highlighted in the June infrastructure
meeting it's got critical
um stage points and we need to know that
you know we're sort of on track
I might hand that one over to my June
and the structure there yeah it's just
it's one of those visible things
thank you through the chair
absolutely we've taken note of that
feedback that we received at the last
finance and projects meeting about
wanting a broader view
um I'm conscious of not wanting to
bombard council with every meter of um
you know curb and channel renewal and
wanting to keep it to those things that
are likely to have Community interest uh
what I'm working with my team on and we
are hoping to pull it together for the
next infrastructure committee meeting at
this stage and Michael and I might just
have to figure out if that's the right
place for it to go but is to the full
list of three Waters renewals as well as
those key projects that we think would
be of particular interest to council
particularly the CCTV project uh the
alternative water supply project and
what's happening with esk Street West
are the ones that we've got on our radar
at the moment so we're we've set
ourselves the challenge of trying to get
that to the next infrastructure
committee meeting conscious that
reporting will have to go through elt
okay next week so we're hoping to make
that but otherwise it will be coming
shortly behind
yeah right uh rangiora is a good point
um because I think from my
interpretation of where things should go
um I would have thought that the
grants committee which is finance and
projects should pick up the likes of
CCTV even though it's an infrastructure
issue to me often infrastructure is a
bit of a business as usual type thing as
Aaron says and I think in relation to
the CC CCTV we've lost a bit of traction
There community we're told that we'd
have this up and running by the last
quarter of this year and I assume to
most lay people that means
the calendar year not the financial year
so if you wanted to spread it I mean
you've got community well-being and this
is actually what CCTV is intentionally
supposed to be yeah you know Community
well-being so sure you're Jacqueline
Darren's one yeah well we just need to
get get it somewhere where we can keep
track of it again people are asking us
when is it coming and we're getting it
from the CBD retailers we're getting it
from the ICL and we're getting from lots
of other places around town that know
that this is coming and I'm wanting to
know when we'll deliver it so yep
Aaron
the only piece I'd add to that is
absolutely agree with the visibility I
think one of the piece we just want to
keep in our thought process is which
meetings we already have key stuff at
um in terms of if we've already got
staff who regularly attend the
infrastructure committee meeting ideally
we wouldn't really want to have them
then spend here for the whole of finance
and projects and here for the whole of
community well-being so just trying to
figure out also from a staffing
perspective where the best fit is as
well okay thank you right yeah thanks uh
cheer look I don't think it's a matter
of where they are the point of that
initial discussion was we need to we're
making decisions and you know CCTV was
one in eastrik whisk in in then we lose
visibility of what's Happening next and
they're not and I think there's a
reference on the minutes here where
they're not projects
we're not asking them to be projects and
then put on the list we just want to
know okay we've made a decision now
where we're at in the process are we
going out for consultation and we're
waiting for Design Concepts whatever
we're at so we can see the progress
because it's really right no sorry
Council Bollinger right right it points
out
um you know air Community is actively
watching these things sure and want them
delivered so we're accountable for the
community yeah and you're quite right
we're galloping
uh with a straight waste towards the
opening of the hotel it's coming around
quite yeah and we've got a significant
amount of work to do then which will
involve public consultation as well yeah
Leslie thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to point out at this juncture because
there's been a lot of talk about the
CCTV project that Council took the
original decision to use our councilor
portfolio system to appoint former
councilor Scout and myself to the CCTV
project and it may be as part of keeping
the project and updates on track that we
want to use a similar
appointment of a couple of counselors to
specifically
steer that project through the rest of
its
coming into being
in fact I'm I am still technically an
appointee for the CCTV project
this is your chance for you
I'm happy to be on that Miss severe yep
well I think you raise a good point
Leslie but unless we have Governors
pushing this along
we've got our staff under oppression and
lots of areas including the museum
it's very easy for us to have a bit of
slippage which is not a criticism of
them it's just we we've got to keep the
front of some of these issues so
yeah it would be on that group the way
to do that was to appoint two councilors
to steer it through the initial you've
got Ria to start with are you still
instant being on there yes I'd still be
interested sure that's cool
okay because I don't think Aaron hears
that
we don't need to move him I was more
than pleased
oh sorry ring it yes look the reason I
I would like some urgency on this is
that last week during the finance
committee I actually sent an email to
senior staff asking a very critical
question
about the CCTV and a certain point of a
decision process that would take part
and I've not heard a response from that
now it wasn't a difficult question
um but if if I'm not getting responses
um I feel like everything is getting
put on a draw somewhere so yeah I just
want to highlight that that I am a bit
worried actually yeah yeah I think
that's it yeah I'm getting a whole lot
of people Tom I see you over there
um look at I mean I think all projects
certainly all significant projects
should be channeled through the project
and finance committee and that should be
the governor's group that
um you know that watches as that goes
through and drives it through obviously
there could be subcommittees that that
um you know which take a particular
accountability
um and admit I don't know if that's you
know Leslie's referring to but I I don't
think we should be creating groups
outside of the committee no
um set up uh and and I think having a
discipline has seen that you know all
projects should be channeled through
um the project and finance group I think
would be useful because otherwise you
end up with too many cooks in the
kitchen yeah
Aaron did you wanna
I was only just going to speak to the
fact that acknowledging councilor
pottinger's lack of response we have had
a staff member on bereavement leave and
we will have that response back to him
as soon as they're back on Deck yep to
me that wasn't necessarily a specific
issue more of a I guess a structural
issue that is how do we keep driving
some of these things forwards Barry yeah
this has been this CCTV thing it's been
been a big thing for me ever since I've
been here
um yeah I'd like to be on it but I think
it's a good Tom's idea of being with
Grant and the Project's committee is a
very good one
and doesn't always require
you'll still have to be here
specifically
unless it was something that was on I
mean we can drive a lot a lot of that
stuff as well
I think I'd be nervous around presenting
information without anybody to talk to
it I think I'd expect that you know part
of the benefit of having that um come up
is the ability to ask questions around
it as opposed to it just simply being a
standing document so we would have to
look through stuff coming up to the
table I think the other thing around
this is
um you know what what Lee does with that
that program dashboard you know I'll be
honest that that's the the top of what
we do in terms of project management in
the organization we don't have that
maturity of project management across
every project that we have in Council
um now not saying we you know that that
may mean a reject to which projects we
have on that strategic projects list but
we also we also need to be conscious of
what's an operational
um you know project that it's okay not
to have necessarily that that high level
of professional project management rigor
around because we don't necessarily want
to project manage the entire business at
that same level
I I guess what we're trying to get here
is um there's some feedback as a
governance group on where we're
progressing with the CCTV and we've got
a lot of commitments to the community
and sometimes you can't be you know we
can't hold people to that
um but certainly as we head in towards
the next round of school holidays which
are coming uh we're getting significant
feedback from the inner city area which
we've we've upgraded for people to say
um retailers to say and others including
the police to say hey we can't manage
some of the teenage Behavior we're
getting in those areas and I've been
party to a couple recently unless we
have some sort of TV coverage that
allows us to track the offenders so
if we can get some update on where
that's happened and so we can tell the
community it'll be here at Christmas or
no it won't be all it'll be staged which
I think is the message I've been trying
to say of course the question incomes as
well when are you starting and I don't
have that so be helpful to just have a
state of the play where we're at with
that
today will reiterate it by having
lesbian Ria the ones driving it is that
we had any letters in the future they
should perhaps come to them and they
drive it through or find out the answers
so that we don't have a lot of
but some pieces around us to make some
progress we really need a sort of one
point of contact and then
from the staff when they're ready or you
know in due time yes
so just as a Michael to my left not to
the right
um it's just suggested that we could add
a portfolio in our government statement
which we're coming up to shortly that
recognize the CCT as being a significant
issue and put the two councils on and
put their hands up that's not to say
that once we have it up and running that
we can't take that portfolio away but it
said it has some significance so this is
any oppositional views against that
we'll make that happen
Mr Arnold um
was better I think this is a project I
think it should be the project
management team
um there's nothing to say that Leslie
and Ria couldn't
um within that group
foreign
portfolio will do wouldn't take it away
from where it reports to it just it
gives some energy to the two people who
are going to try and drive it I think
one of the issues that we face with
hindsight which is a beautiful thing is
that when we set this up we had quite a
few people on that original group we had
Mary wardens we had police and we had
different retailers on which is
they are but the trouble is when you put
together a big group like that and
you're trying to drive a project with me
quickly
um you sort of lose that ability to get
it Forward sometimes I think
um so anyway if there's no position
we'll have those two names added
right brief discussion on there
we just need to put oh okay so
um this is any further discussion I'll
just put the uh minutes with the
recommendation of the finance and
project committee
to the group and we'll do some favor I
carried
no some motion that we have a request
for an update from the Great South on
planned oat milk
agree so before I give rangi the chance
to talk to his nose emotion just for
those that are new this term or even
newer again
just the process with notice the motion
as it is is such that um there are
special rules and standing orders around
speaking rights to annotation so rang
you'll get the first chance to speak
others can contribute as well
some argue that once you've got three
people talking to their firmers or three
to the negative that's where it stops
but that's not my flavor to any meeting
and so but um I will have a degree of
tolerance for rangi to have a right to
reply seeing it says motion to people
that might raise issues as well so you
can have a slight debate back with that
person if they want and at the end the
motion gets put
ringing the floor is yours now thank you
Mr Mayor look it's it's pretty
straightforward and it's wording and I
just like to
at this stage read the notice motion and
that is the council formally via the
chief executive request that
representatives of Great South attend
the September 26th council meeting
and explain the circumstances and events
that has led
to the planned Oak milk factory no
longer being located in the south island
so
that's me for now yep thank you I'll
take the first chance to comment to that
so um for me personally I support that I
think the and I've been quite open with
the media and with great South itself I
think the comms are all media around
this uh whole debate around this whole
issue has been very poor it's left a
whole lot of question marks both at this
Council table and in The Wider Community
as well
just a reflection in your summary ring
at the very end it talks about us being
responsible as like the members
um to ensure such money so I'll move
wisely and I just didn't want any
confusion about that people understand
that we have not put money into the
company as such so we haven't put any
operating costs or Capital there never
appears refers to our funding of Great
South great yeah I just want them to
understand that because over the 10 or
12 years it's been going we've probably
through operating funds put a
significant amount of money into
developing on this project sorry for the
confusion yeah that's why it's all good
and yes Tom
um certainly support the motion was
submit it's essential that we get it
safe to come and speak to us but I would
also suggest that it's essential that we
were sold judgment
and any further come in until we
actually give them the opportunity to do
that
thank you for that and I can just add to
that um I was notified very early in the
process
um in relation to um the decision by the
board board of New Zealand functional
foods to go away from Southland and head
towards Canterbury
but there are commercial negotiations
going on about whether
Great South which we own exits the
company or stays within the company
and they are very sensitive at the
moment and this is not me trying to
fault anybody off
and um
so yeah right the right negotiations and
going but by the time rainy motion comes
to light which is next month I would
expect a great South to be in a position
to update us around a couple of things
uh the position they took on the board
when they let us know and what the
impacts are of staying in the company or
coming out of the company and that they
are still commercially sensitive we
still need to have that advice and I've
told Ian Collier that and if it's still
commercially sensitive we'll have it
within PE if not then we'll have it out
on the table where everybody can
understand what's going on
yeah
uh thank you Mr Mia
um I also support um Corona Portugal's
notices of motion along the same lines
as what you've already said and what
Tom's brought up as well was we need to
be careful that we've heard from them
um their reasoning behind this um
if you like backtrack one of the things
that I guess in this process leading up
to this really disappointing outcome is
that we had the CE here
um talking to us we had the wonderful
public meeting saying how great they
were doing and funding and what was on
Horizon and literally within a week or
so
um
this has been put to the public that
they were wanting to move the site to to
Christchurch so I think it is essential
that that we do require them here they
need to be accountable for what's
happened and it needs to be completely
transparent with this Council
so I've I've personally asked Ian
because I'm an ongoing discussions
around this some things which I can
share with you I've asked him when he
comes forward to rangi's meeting next
meeting that Rangers requiring next
month we want to know when he knew that
the decision was up on the table given
that he's on the functional foods board
tweet and we want to know that in
alignment with the Beyond 2025 which is
a big promotion that they know
beforehand or did they know Arthur
um so I want some specifics around that
I also want to know how he voted at the
at the at the time given that we are a
minority shareholder in the company
um so um the other partner has 51
percent so and and what was his thinking
around that
um was he
um I guess
should he have required a a vote of hey
we don't want to go down this track or
what was he in a position that he
couldn't make that decision being a
minority shareholder and then
subsequently needed what's the best deal
I can get out of this for the
shareholders that he does represent so
there's some real tough questions around
that there is and I expect answers to
those
dude
Leslie
thank you Mr mere
um not opposed to the notice of motion
per se but I will go a bit into some
history in making a comment here
um
the whole Oak notes project started out
as a venture Southland project
so we all know it's been a very long
term project
this Council and councilor pottinger
will remember he was one of the main
proponents of replacing the then Venture
Southland structure with what has become
great sell with a much more commercially
focused independent award
doing that does bring the consequences
we asked for a board that was more
commercially focused and our partners in
the Venture agreed with us we have a
great South board that was there to make
commercial decisions
the oak milks project has got to that
stage decisions have been made I think
as the deputy mayor said we very much
have to wait for the report before any
judgments are made about that commercial
decision on behalf of a board that this
Council actually helped to put in place
as an improvement on what was seen as
the Venture South instructor not working
as it should in the commercial sense
so I do have some reservations about any
of this discussion if the questions you
have indicated are to be answered
actually being held and anything but in
committee and I do think this that has
to be stated at this point that this may
be an in committee discussion because we
have a board that we agreed was a more
commercially or had more Community
commercial Acumen that's why they're
there where you have to accept that that
may bring certain consequences we know
that we are a minority shareholder and a
49 shareholder is not a 51 shareholder
so I'm just indicating very strongly
that this discussion may be necessary to
be held in committee and that there may
be only a very small part of it able at
the present time to be held in public
and I'm aware we're talking about the
26th of September but that is not far
away in the commercial decision world
and I just would not like the public to
believe that there is going to be a
fully public grilling of the board of
great sale on the 26th of September that
may not be the reality of what we're
facing
yeah before we hear what you're saying
and it would be my expectation that we
wouldn't go down that path either but we
will then subsequently to have some
really sharp comps coming out of there
so that people do get some information
about what's what's transpired
and I guess just for laypeople and on on
probiotic category as well but we've got
other people around the table time and
Grant in particular who will know more
about this and me
um it's not necessarily how much shares
you've got in the company the rubber
hits the road when you get investment
capital investment comes in
so we've got one big pattern already
there but we've got another one
signaling and when they come in what
shares you've got they can then get
diluted down significantly and so I
guess that's one of the things we need
to understand is how well has great
South and it's both positioned us for
that capital investment that's coming in
and and as we're indicating it has to be
a session that has gone into very much
with an open mind and with the
consideration that most of it may
have to be in committee because of the
commercial sensitivity we should lead
the public to believe otherwise at this
stage yeah well I think if you
don't have a purpose but if you heard
the way I originally said that I said
that this will probably have to be all
in PE unless unless great chef gives us
a a hands up that they're okay with it
to be in public and I don't think
that'll be the case it'll be too early
uh four weeks from now but we do need to
understand what's going on there
I mean it's a little bit like
at the same time you've got that we've
got the salmon farm consent tonight a
good example is I've been into night I
recently said what's going on
you know where are you guys going to
take this or not because I'd like to
know but it's commercially sensitive for
them and it's decision making at the
very top of the tribe
um and so I get a bit of water silence
and quite rightly so
um they need to be considered about what
they do as well for sure and we'd all
like to see a Sam Farm we'd all like to
see the open up as well
um
Peter yeah uh thank you Mr Mayor
personally I'm very disappointed and
annoyed this proposed
planned oatmeal factories not being
built in South and I totally uh agree
with
Council Partners motion and also the
comments that counselor Campbell has
made also
I think it's a reasonable reflection
Peter that there'd be nobody around this
table that wasn't disappointed that
that's not here I mean I've had people
from all over the community and see me
including the oak Growers themselves to
say that they're really really
frustrated by this so we need to
understand why
Trish I think the thing excuse me I
think the thing for me was that we were
sideswiped by the communications that
went out yeah is a counselor we didn't
know anything that we didn't answer
anything yep
die quietly
but you're right treasure I said that in
the opening game yeah that um
the comms was not good at all
um it was very important and they
acknowledged that so we've got some
ground to recover
nobody else any other
a right of reply there rangi
so look all I want to say and
um
is it Great South is a council
controlled organization and as a CCO
under the Local Government Act
it's required to operate in accordance
with a statement of intent now the Great
South statement of intent has dedicated
section at the end entitled shareholder
requirements
within this is two sub sections of node
one is no surprises and that's followed
by a second subsection called public
expectations and in that
um it has an interesting sentence to
committing to transparency and
accountability to the public so that is
contained within their statement of
intent so I believe that this Council
and the public have the right to know
has great South
complied with its statement of intent
now this does not need to be answered in
public excluded we are talking simple
um this is in the Local Government Act
it's it's I can't see any reason why
discussing
uh the statement of intent would need to
be it's got nothing to do with outs
um
so that's my view on
putting all this in PE I I I believe
um this part which is very important to
me wouldn't would be fine in public and
advice from the CE
Maybe
Michael would you have any comment
regarding that
uh through yourself Mia um
it's it's a tricky situation in relation
to the public excluded
um From perspective of what you raise uh
what you raise yes that is a public can
be a public discussion however I think
what's been highlighted in the previous
discussions give rise to some commercial
sensitivity in relation to some of the
other topics that need to be discussed
but it is very hard to split to in
relation to that session
my advice in relation to it would be to
have the discussion in the public
excluded with a view to actually
promptly release the
the
nature of the discussion out to the
public straight after that meeting
except for those that are still
commercially sensitive no I'll take the
advice thank you and certainly from my
end as well
as we come to this issue next month we
will have I suspect a recommendation on
the table for PE
but we have control over there
um and so we'll make decisions about
whether it's SNP or not in PE we can do
that at any meeting and being mindful of
what something else I've seen
so there's no further things obviously
you put the motion I will move that yeah
I'll I'll second
um
any further discussion on that
all those in favor all right anybody
opposed
thank you
next a general item is the connected
murihiku joint committee nomination
so I'll take that as being read I've got
a range of issues within that so um
oh sorry Rihanna
[Music]
can you hear me all right uh kyota says
Okay so this first paper on connected
joint committee nomination is a
procedural paper and you'll recall that
you received the earlier paper about
setting up the appointments committee
that appointments committee has met they
have selected three very talented
Community Representatives
um which is detailed within the paper
and this is now the next stage of the
process which is to confirm council's
representation and Alternate and to
approve the Joint Committee
um
terms of reference so just a reminder
that council's role in this Regional
project is we are providing the support
the governance support for the project
less buzzy
okay
um sorry I've distracted myself so just
to confirm and remind you that council's
role in this project is a regional
project that's come through the just
transitions process we are providing the
administrative support to the Joint
Committee through the early stages
okay so um we've got a suite of
recommendations here before we get into
that
um I guess I just want to make my
position known so there are two issues
for me one is for Pioneer and for Evelyn
I noticed that they call the group
um connected Murray Hickory joint
it's it's more hiku an okay part of that
title given that Marik is much wider
than where this is going
I'm not not trying to be facetious right
but we had that with the museum that you
didn't want marikou because it's a much
bigger geographical patch
so Mr chair
the Veronica's position is clear that we
do not refer to South America goes to
the waitaki however we do also recognize
that
um
we're not the only people who live in
the community
um and some people do think many Hickory
has the right to him
connecting South and would do fine for
me
um I'm not sure
you know I I'm not going to die in the
ditch about it but my preference would
be that it didn't say marijeku because
that means that we're going across the
boundary and doing
um
we don't want to do that
I I personally don't have a position on
it and it might give one said
um a lot of uh our community Mali
Community referred to South and that's
marijuana okay and
so before it opens yep so I guess
whoever the Reps into visit we got more
about to nominate
um
could just take that forward with their
personal present
the other thing for me is that I've um
got a personal position on this which I
don't agree with
um
the whole
focus of this this group I think it will
achieve nothing at the end of the day
and I don't take any pleasure of saying
that but when you look at the major
Focus there are two components to it one
part is to connect up all the uh
agencies which include government and
non-government agencies that might uh
that might help in a particular area of
making us connected and it doesn't say
whether it's just in Social Services
it's actually much wider than that
so that's going to be an online presence
that they're going to do so it'll be
like an electronic dictionary about
agencies that might be able to help you
if you needed help doing some work
um the downside of that is that's a heap
of work
and an agency in Town's already done
that so I've got the list there which is
about 85 agencies long so I don't see
why we reinvent that list anyway
um and the other issue for me personally
is that it's been my experience in
Social Services is that you the agencies
need to connect with each other
so that when they need that connection
the connection's already built as
opposed to having one coordinator that
just coordinates all the agencies in
town and a good example of that is
recently we had the Southern Regional
leadership group over the tail end of
covert which it worked well in one looks
big but the respective didn't work well
and it wasn't coordinated we had 85
stakeholders on it and so while it was
nice to hear what the prison was doing
in relation to covert it really turned
off a whole lot of other people that
were working at other spheres so um I'm
not sure what it'll achieve I think
we'll end up at the end of the day of
having somebody that's trying to connect
with probably about 120 groups
um where the the coordinator making that
connection won't actually connect the
groups themselves and and they shouldn't
get them into the big room and if you
try and get 120 or even subsets of 30
into it you won't you won't get that
connection that you need to do the work
um and the online presence I could do
that tomorrow with the list that I've
already got so that's more than we
statement on that I accept that we're
down the track and I'm not opposed to
people doing what they want to do
yep so Grant I've got you Evelyn
yeah thanks chip
um
of a similar view to yourself in the
sense of reading through this I can't
see what this will achieve other than a
whole lot of sort of getting together in
Cups of Tea which is all very well but I
can't understand the outcome of it and I
note the reference through to the
taranaki Wheelhouse
um
structure and it's hard to see what's
being achieved there the other thing I'd
look at in terms of the delegations on
page 71 of board box or four of the
papers
it seems to be an agency that's
appointed or going to administer the
work from central government be it MB
um Innovation
um
those sorts of things
and they'll carry out the activities in
0.5 so
yeah is is this entity in
what I'm trying to understand is what
what pairs are we giving to this
committee to go and decide on the things
that are important for invercargill
because it's a regional
um Regional entity and we've probably
got an example of another Regional
entity that's what
but unclear how it's working at the
moment for air City and so that's the
concern that I have is that
um are we giving
um delegating Authority and
decision-making pairs do they seem to
see and then losing all control for it
City in terms of develop you know air
needs and those sorts of things and then
secondly and I think this is really
important central government funding
comes down in this entity is going to be
the decider of those where those funds
go and I'm just not comfortable with it
if I haven't seen it work well
today that I'm don't know whether I'll
see it work well in the future yep I
guess just I'll get there buddy I'll see
the hands going on
um just in response to that Grant um
you know I've worked on a family Start
program and one of the successes we had
in the family Start program was to have
some Central agency delivering a service
so this one was delivering to mums with
young babies
and we needed about 85 Partners to be
able to do that and we spent best part
of three years connecting with those
people one agency per week for three
years it took a heap of time but you
needed the personal connection you just
didn't need a list if your ring up
Taylor
on Chris boil from education they don't
know you and and Personnel will change
so this list has got quite a bit on it
the other thing is that it's not
necessarily connecting us
if you look at the specs it's also
covers central government as well so
we're really linking in the I guess the
silos that sit in Wellington or might
sit out in Regional structures as well
so it's going to be a huge beast but at
the end of the day I still don't know
um what we'll achieve by that I just
don't get it it talks about the database
having
um
about also covering what they describe
quoting best practice well if you go to
the Social Services field
there for years discussing what's good
practice or best practice so
I've got a whole lot of names here
everyone
um
for me having sat through the or
participated in the one I know that that
produce this initiative I think there's
a misconception about what it will is
intended to do so this is about if you
are in a remote area and you are a new
mum and you wanting to see if you can
find a support in your area
you know perhaps you're new in that area
you can go on a digital platform and
dial up what you want and get the sort
of support
it may end up doing other things at
making it due to MEC or
parent line or any of those things
because they're all relevant but the
idea is that all in one place
somebody that is just down the road an
organization that is in your nearest
little small village or your
or your nearest hub center or
a volunteer that has said that they will
spend their time talking you through
this issue you might want to know is
there somebody in your area that is
running a
a knitting club or a book club or you
might want to know something much more
in-depth is there anybody in your
community that actually
um
is easily accessible for JP Services all
those sorts of things now we might think
oh that information is there but it's in
so many different places and the idea of
this is that any group that wants to
have this well that was my understanding
of it any group that wants two pops
their services forward to community will
be able to be accessible from there this
is about
something that we experienced during
covert which was our lack of
connectivity to one another and how do
you access
these conversations if you don't know
where to start I accept that it sounds a
little bit big brother-ish but it's
actually you being able to access
central government services not central
government services telling you
how to live your life if we look at what
some of our community said
in fact a lot of the community who were
represented there is the disconnection
between agencies that even agencies in
the same area don't always know what is
offered by somebody you know we get new
contracts all the time as social service
providers as Health Service Providers
it's really difficult for our companion
agencies always to keep up with what
who is delivering what and so we don't
all get big splashes on the front page
of the paper like nakizi did sometimes
it's just a very quiet contract and you
just go about doing the business
how do we connect people up to that
service so I understand why you might be
skeptical but I don't see any decision
making in this this is about information
acquisition and dismissal as far as my
understanding of the project and if I've
misunderstood it Rhiannon will no doubt
tell me but
for me
that's the fruit of the work is to
connect people up to things that they
need to be able to get to easily
thank you for sharing that Ellen
and you hang up oh no just the piano
well Alex
I'm just working off a list from
personal rights of the left hand my
apologies it was Alex because I crack it
sorry
that's you it is me fantastic thank you
very much
um awesome to hear the corridor uh
around this stuff but I think it's more
um just a slight little bit um
of a shifted understanding of what this
project actually is so Central
regardless of whether or not we appoint
somebody this work is going to continue
anyway so it's whether or not we want to
have
um a hand and steering how the
allocation of the funding uh goes and
and what it does in the community
secondly
um for the appointments to this
committee a focus was on making this
entity self-sustaining so we asked the
candidates who came along right how are
you going to guide whoever's appointed
into making sure that this model is
self-sustaining so that because
obviously for us a focus was not having
this come and knock on our door for
additional funding in future
um so yeah if that if it continues if we
don't put it for delegate or an
alternate the project still continues
it's Central government's funding it's
not our funding so we don't have a
mandate we're not delegating anything
there's no
um I guess risk from our perspective in
the sense that it's going to run off
with our money it's not our money
um I think it's also really important
like when not to look a gift horse in
the mouth like this is an amazing amount
of funding for a project that's going to
connect our rural
um into separate communities our
Multicultural commune communities that
come in and don't have uh I guess access
to support networks like this
it actually is in like Grant said
modeled off um a successful uh pilot
project in the north island called The
Wheelhouse which pulled together the
list um in like Mia Clarke said probably
utilized the list of 84 agencies or
whatever it is as a foundation
um platform to start from but
um also covers things like training
um mentorship
um all uh how to access other funding
streams if you're an organization and
invercargill
um all sorts of things
um to try to you know like give that
Community hub for somebody who who might
be feeling a little bit lonely or a bit
um disconnected and it is all stem from
like um
Reverend seed from the kaupapa of
connecting all of our communities so
like I think it's really important that
we we don't lose sight of the fact we
don't want to look a gift horse in the
mouth and this is absolutely something
that we want to be involved with whether
or not we do it or not which is in this
case we're not doing it we want to make
sure that out there in our community
that there's as much opportunity for
connection as is possible
So yeah thank you for listening to my
rant
it was okay feedback for both you and
and from everyone as well and it wasn't
my intention to
um
to not have us involved we need to be
involved but I just wanted us to be
clear that this could be an area that we
don't get results that we might be might
be wanting but it was interesting I mean
I
um went to a meeting at Mirai last week
and a race with Odell you know how how
many um she won't mind me saying this
how many how many support agencies are
there in the city and I get this
commonly with everybody including a
large government house oh there's a
couple dozen so it was actually 85 and
the list is growing every day so we
don't know where those are those other
support agencies are so I guess
grant were you uh
thank you Mr Mayor Al Cricket gave a
pretty comprehensive Global picture so
I'm not going to repeat the things there
that I agreed with but I do just want to
say
is council's representative on the
citizens advice Bureau that the citizens
advice Bureau holds part of the database
but not the entire database that this is
aimed at building so while agencies like
citizens advice have very good databases
and are one
ever knew of conduct for many of the
people that counselor cricket and um
Reverend cook were talking about wanting
access somehow this can only build
better and from that point of view Alone
um I'm in favor of us appointing a
representative on an alternate
um because it's Council of cricket
eloquently said why would we look a gift
horse in the mouth of it's actually
going to improve their Community
outcomes
thank you grant
all right my mind I was going to put my
hand up so having heard the wonderful
explanations of this yeah how we're
going to measure the outcomes so you
know how we're going to measure
and there's nothing in the paper that me
tells us how that's going to be measured
yeah the number of people that are
accessing it what the change and
differences in their life because I
don't disagree with the concept and
Theory but the difference between Theory
and reality is what difference are we
making to people's lives and there's no
management accountability or outcome
accountability in that in the statement
that I can see that's clear and obvious
sake because of this people's lives have
changed yeah through the chair if I may
um to answer grants sure question
um that will be developed and
orchestrated by that advisory committee
once the appointment's been made so kpis
established and that report all of those
reporting lines established
um and then the advisory committee
minutes will be put forward here you
know like so we will have oversight from
oversight from a governance perspective
so if you took a sorry just a reply but
you took a commercial perspective you'd
expect to see the outcomes in a business
case before you agreed it not approve it
and then hope that the business comes
along because and to my very point
how can we be clear of the outcomes Ipsy
that are waxed about are actually going
to be delivered and what's the
accountability to this committee if
they're not so again it's central
government that will be requesting that
not us I know and that's probably the
very reason why we're here and even the
discussion because of the Civil central
government issue where there's no
accountability and there's no measured
outcome it's just let's do this project
and it's going to be wonderful and I
don't disagree with which has been said
but what I want to see is that
accountability around what are the
changes to people's lives a result of
this investment
because there's probably a million
dollars sprinkled in here through the
chair yeah can I just add here that
until it started to be built
you can't have the outcomes in any
detail because at the moment this
project is talking about building
blocks
so until you've actually built something
it's a little bit hard to zero in on it
on the exact outcomes you are expecting
from something that is not yet fully
built we know that there are bits of
databases
all over the place that need connected
we know that that's a job that is going
to take quite some expertise
I can see a great deal of logic in
actually getting this up and running to
the point where you actually
um write kpis that make some sense it's
a little bit difficult to do it right at
this point where you haven't got
anything built it's it's almost like a
build up and they will come we've got to
build at first and the building block to
start us is to get this committee
underway
all right come back to that Tom I've
still got your Rihanna
yeah sure
um look I I think I'm certainly
convinced that the need particularly in
the basis of you know Evelyn's um speech
which I thought articulated it extremely
well
um the only concern I had I did actually
voice it when this people came up as the
last time a few months ago as it seems
to me just to be grossly over governed I
mean you know there was a mural Forum
decision and I'm not gonna you know
um question wisdom in the middle Forum
but they never knew how the whole thing
would follow but it was a mere Forum
decision that would be a joint committee
so we have a joint committee which will
manage and govern the work of one person
coordinator
and although we can say well the joint
committee is made up of people who are
either volunteers or counselors who have
been you know paid anyway but their time
has value
so it just seems to me to be over
governed and and I would probably
have rather seen it I'm going to support
it anyway but I think I would rather
have seen it probably tucked in the
Great South or something like that but
there's three people we've got Robin
Jason sorry what was the third name
again
Robin Jess and Steve who look excellent
choices as Community Representatives
acted as a sort of steering committee of
that individual working at 10 degrees
remember that ship has sealed but I I
just think it ends it's just overcome
and the individual who does a job is
going to have um you know constantly
trade what was the Joint Committee and
and that's one of the things that I did
a quick calculator on I think the uh the
group that we're
nominating representative to if you
include alternates could very well be 11
12 or 13 people at least
um so anyway that's not what we're here
for today uh Rhiannon I'm going to give
you the chance to
say a few things
um all I just wanted to just make a
comment on from a procedural point of
view
um which Tom actually touched on is that
this project has been shaped up through
various way Gates through the MB process
which was required
um councils were rolled through that
whole process has simply been in the
support has not been in terms of shaping
up what the project looks like the
project has come from the community
and the governance structure has come
from the Merrell Forum when they're
considered five different options in a
detailed discussion the Merrell Forum
then provided the support for the
project and and the project is
proceeding at the regional level the
intention is that the Joint Committee
will do themselves out of a job in 18
months and replace it with a much more
Nimble structure it is I agree a weighty
governance structure but it has been put
together with thought because one of the
things that has come strongly through
this whole process is how important
representation is to everybody
um it was important to the council
participants it was important to the
runaker participants and ultimately what
the community wants is a Nimble
governance structure that doesn't
involve such a formal process
but a transitional step is needed so
um I hope that gives some reassurance to
you all that it is intended to be a
transitional Step at present time the
funding involved is 200 000 that does
not cover icc's contribution which is in
supporting the governance in the
administration which is not a small
amount of work that is nevertheless a
large way through the first meeting is
planned for the 31st of August
um and that's all the point that I just
wanted to make thank you
in Rio
um actually uh Rhiannon sort of
nicely summarize what I was going to say
because I only agreed to go on this on
the basis that it was relatively
speaking and short term a short-term gig
I don't see
my intention of being there forever
um
even less than 18 months would be nice
from my perspective but it's not a job
for life
um a committee that's going to be
overwhelming forever and thank you
Rhiannon for addressing that issue
because I think that's important people
understand that it's just to get things
off the ground
reading your lips are here did you want
to say something oh I was just going to
say that um things were in for the
clarification in terms of the um they
might very well do themselves have a job
in 18 months time I'm interested with
the amount that you've given us at mbia
putting into this what is the council's
commitment to that
okay icc's commitment is in-kind support
for the governance structure at this
point yeah
yeah thank you
Alex oh thank you cheers the last one um
I would may I please um nominate myself
as the ultimate I haven't got the fire
yet just wanting to know when there's
any further discussion
thank you Mr chair I was actually going
to nominate
alternate just to move things on because
I thought we were at that point yeah
okay
so nominations and yeah if I
reason for that is I really believe in
the kaupapa and I really wish that I
could be the representative as just the
meetings that we've had so far and the
ones that seem to be working with the
Joint Committee are all on Thursdays and
that's a day that I'm really struggling
to getting to get to at the moment so
more than happy to be the alternate but
if I could like it myself people people
self-nominate because it shows have come
up somebody else or second there no I've
got the fire treasure will you put your
hand up I don't want to do it yeah you
want to be the representative
is there any interest anywhere else on
being the primary representative
couch
could I suggest that perhaps we nominate
councilor cricket
and into discussions on the meetings
been being held at a different time
um so um
Evelyn
you're already there
well I was thinking about that I if the
council were willing I don't see that
I've been conflict wearing two hats it's
not like I'm going to be arguing against
now what I was suggesting is
whether it's possible to move it away
from a Thursday meeting
um so the Thursday meeting is not
particularly dictated by me but it is
there is some practical considerations
for it not being a Tuesday for example
um so I guess Rhiannon
I'm not sure about the discussions about
meeting dates going forward because we
have that at the inaugural meeting
so where does that Levy Alex
well I'm having a chat online learn a
friend here
um
yeah I'm up into it but I I hear
some really good I really agree with a
lot of what crowd is saying I probably
am a big picture what does indoor look
like what a success criteria look like
uh with a model that that has worked and
so I think my
um hey look I'm Keen to dive in and get
get more understanding but I want to see
a model that I think will work and build
up a Real Results and so I
well that sounds like an ideal situation
where I'll nominate councilor Broad and
councilor Cricket last second
[Laughter]
and perhaps the the best the best idea
the best Direction at this moment is to
nominate both and for them to work out
depending on the setting of meetings
which one would be most sensible to be
the representative and which would be
the alternate yeah and come back to us
yeah
any other hand are these two positions
they're being none congratulations
well done
I promise you it's going to be great
yeah
I can promise that we'll do it
we look forward to the report don't aim
for the moon and end up on March
to write that down
further okay
we've got a suite of um
Barry was that you all those in favor
aye great you got that Alex
we just moved all those six Suites your
nomination excellent
um next the general item is Civic Awards
so you worship
um I ask for this to to come forward and
followed an approach from a member of
the public and I certainly
um support us for introducing the
opportunity to recognize people who
volunteer within the community and
they've given a great service an
artist's Court may also sit in there
somewhere as well just I'm not 100 sure
on why it's being referred back to the
community well-being fund committee but
um
but it's in the recommendations and
so so given your experience what are you
recommending to us in relation to the
time frames an annual or a tri-annual
things
okay yeah
rainy
look I would support this as long as we
show consistency to the way it was run
previously
um and then you know it keeps apples
with apples and yeah
okay I think we if we should run it
around it I think it's an excellent idea
I believe we should run it annually and
my reasoning for that is we there are a
number of people in our community who
could be eligible for these Awards and
to do it every three years we're missing
a whole lot of people and I think well
that's just my reason I I'd love to see
it you know
um happen and but I would like to see it
annually
uh before I come back to you there
um this is an opposing thought to that I
just one of the things is when you have
an annual award you've got a full year
fill the list up as it were sometimes
and you can sometimes struggle to get
I shouldn't say quality people but you
feel as a and then you'll always come up
so you've got to have X amount of people
nominated or whatever
so I'm going to go back to Grant sorry
to Grant
sorry
yeah
I I agree
um the Civic awards are special and and
they recognize people who've made
significant contribution either on the
local stage or on the international
stage and
while I understand the sentiment of
having something that recognizes people
uh annually there are things like the
kiwibank volunteer Awards like that but
but these are special and coming back to
what councilman Parton just said you
know but we did it once a trianium
previously that were not huge numbers of
people being inducted just to to make
sure that there is a significant
threshold
um so I'm happy to
um
move the recommendations but ask
officers to work with their Community
well-being committee
to finalize and deliver the awards
because I'm not on the well-being fund
committee and I've quite like to have a
hand on it I'm sure oh I'll second that
presuming that we're saying we agree to
reinstate them and number two that we
make them torini or number try any or
number three and that we change number
four to the community well-being
committee
hello
well so actually yeah I'm thinking that
um Patricia's idea is probably a better
idea I'd rather see it an annual thing
and it doesn't have to be 15 nominations
I mean there might only be one there
might only be two there might be none
some here but at least when the
the thought for that person to be what
was now to be put forward it's fresh I
mean three years later down the track
it's almost yeah yeah possibly too late
so I think it should be done manually
and it doesn't matter if there's one
none or three yeah and I think so I'd
support the motion but I'd like to see
it annually I suppose to trainingly oh
yeah and thank you Mr Mia
um I I support one and two I do um think
that to
I'm more of a biannual person
um
because I've we've done I haven't
returned ticket to tie
hey and I'll go
but just just with having I mean not not
arrange Civic Awards but other Awards
would like-minded Community people that
don't do significant work
um I the training was too long you could
be basically awarding a person that's
already passed over an award not had the
significant
um happiness that actually been
recognized for their their huge
contribution to our community which is
why I'm trying to compromise and go you
know buying always better than a
triangle I agree with that going to the
community wellbeing subcommittee
um we have our hands inside of the
community there a lots of stars come
through
um and it's I think it's positive for us
to recognize those members in our
community that are giving significantly
locally and nationally yes we do have
loads of awards Nationwide around this
country and I think it's time that we
put these back into our priorities
you know I agree with what Ria is saying
there I think it should be by a annual
and totally supported going with the
community yeah well-being
it's my thoughts on it
so so I'll put the Motions in two forms
one that we agree or don't agree with
having sounds like we will agree and
then I'll open up the options to one two
or three yearly and we'll just do a
straw poll to start with just to get an
idea where the feel is around the table
um and then we can put a motion based on
there so I think the problem you've got
is that you've got to be removed already
yeah just a point of clarification yeah
um Miss Mir was around uh she shows that
95 96 97 no Awards made now was that for
a a reason of civil unrest or was it
there was no one no one available to
choose or just just wondering if there's
a reason obviously covert has been
stated for other reasons but
it's got 95 96 97 no Awards made but if
they're a triangular it's only one year
no no no these were all these were year
after year back then oh sorry that
predates anyone at this table
86 we had no Awards made oh no no but it
just seems weird that you would not find
a person in those three years
going to Enlighten us
so just to note that it has been a
fairly kind of informal process that has
flexed and been run differently at
different times and my understanding is
that in those years there were no
applications that the committee felt
and I noticed that finish in 2016 there
were other councilors around at that
time and I wonder whether
to be
a a thing at that time because
um it was felt to be you know too
difficult I mean you've got to choose
people
um what's the selection panel look like
how do you make sure that the most
worthy people are being nominated not
just people who have to be known by some
of them and you know I I feel a little
bit okay and
there are many people who are deserving
you these Awards I noticed when I look
at the last small very small number of
people who are I should be nominated
over the years I recognize quite a lot
of the names which makes me think that
they were
I'm not me I don't mean related
personally but we're known to Council in
some way
um rather than necessarily people who
are the most deserving so I feel a
little bit uncomfortable with them I'm
going to vote against it but I don't
think we should jump in here this is
actually quite difficult process it was
a work with a lot of administration I
would think and collecting the
denominations and then make sure that
judgments are made clearly how do you
you know what does fairly mean is it
just on the basis of you know what the
committee thinker is or some criteria
okay so
um
the
panel who decide first of all
nominations were Corporal from the
public and so it wasn't done from within
Council
and there were people who were nominated
who the judging panel didn't
feel meet the criteria it wasn't a
reflection on
uh the work that they had done but it
was more the standard
um of the criteria that was expected the
judging panel at that time was the mayor
Deputy Mayor and the chief executive it
doesn't need to be there I had an
opportunity to be on it except my
father-in-law was nominated so I didn't
take part at all but I think this is
part Tom Rose has some really good
points and I think this is part of what
um the officers can work with the the
committee to to finalize before we put
it out there
just to make sure that there is
consistency and that comes down to how
we recognize them as well
so are you recommending that we
work through that process before we
agree on whether we're going to have it
or not
it would be there's no point working
through the process if we don't want to
have them okay
that we couldn't be officers to bring
forward sorry through your chip yeah
sure we couldn't invite officers to
bring forward the kind of scale it and
hurt me working and maybe an assessment
to hear they would you know who they
would manage it we would be voting then
in the business a little bit more
information than we do now I'm not
looking just to kick any touch yeah I
just feel it's an easy thing you see yep
that's a really good idea
and then find you know
I think look I agree I think a paper
would be useful and I think a paper
worth some feedback from staff around
admin might help to inform the decision
around how frequently it's done as well
actually all encompassed in the um the
motion that's already been yeah
can we follow standing orders please
sure one speaker at a time
okay ringy
um look I'd like to add one that um that
elector members aren't eligible for the
role that they play as elected members
they may have done some other thing in
the community which has opened some
eligibility but I'm serving on Council I
don't believe is
um is something that that makes you
eligible so I just like to throw that in
there because
not knocking any of the names previously
but you know moving forward if we're
going to have a paper
then that's something to consider
well that's my people sure Trish just
before you start
I mean one of the areas to cover for you
Tom might bring will be that we have a
dual award system where we might also
have an individual recognized but we
could also have an organization
recognized as well which might capture a
much wider group of people and recognize
what they do in the community as well
treasure
I'm not suggesting that the wellbeing
fund does this but the wellbeing fund
has a very clear criteria and it gives
you a percentage to that criteria which
would mean if we use something similar
then we would award or not depending on
whether they meet the criteria
yeah
Rhiannon and you're the last speaker to
this thinking
I was just gonna give a comment to the
question that's come up around
um resources and how how resource
intensive it would be
um so the reason for the recommendation
to include it within the delegations for
the community well-being fund
subcommittee was to speak to this matter
of providing support for the processes
efficiently as possible and hence also
the suggestion to restructure the way
that the awards are communicated
slightly so wouldn't exclude anything
that was covered before but would align
it with the well-beings and the
priorities that councils
um given that was given with the viewers
to be the most efficient way to provide
this resource obviously doing it
annually will be more labor intensive
than doing it trianially or by annually
okay
well I'll put two parts to the thing
I'll put the first part which is um
do we want the awards and then we can
come to the issue of the the timing with
the Mover and signals off so
I'll just put the motion that um
that we that we agree into to having
severe award reinstated
yeah all those in favor all right
carried
um now we come to the issue of whether
it's annual or triannual and I'll just
sort some advice
from Michael to my left that I can do a
straw poll just initially to decide
whether we wanted annual bi-annual or
tri-annual with the ability to condense
that list down to two and then with the
blessing of those that move the motion
and seconded they would be the two
options that we'd put
so can you refresh my memory about who
the nominator who the movement right
Darren and Leslie the standard two
that's cool so I'll come back to YouTube
later on to see whether you're happy
with that process
if we reduce down
otherwise the only two options we're
going to have on the table is either
annual or triangle
it was moved as triennial
okay well I'll test the water if it
doesn't go down that track with training
if there are people opposed to it which
will include those that are supportive
of annual or bi-annual then the boat
will go accordingly and then we'll come
back to what we want and subsequent to
that so I'll put the issue of the um
and and three on the issue of
um it being on a triennial basis and all
those in favor can show their hands so I
get a feel for this
is
opposed to buy or
or annual which is one unit one two
three four so that motion is defeated
and so now I guess we come back to the
issue of uh annual or bi-annual
somebody like to move them
one of those two I'd like to move annual
annual album
segment by Grant and I'll put that again
and if it's default it'll be back out to
buying so all those in favor was a show
of hands on annual
four five
and I'm there as well so that's six
yeah congratulations
so that's lost as well so by default
we're back to buying you
majority
yeah do the show hands again to make
sure that everybody's clear about this
because we want an outcome that we we
live with that's where we've been taken
what we're voting on is annual versus
bi-annual
um and so I just need to show hands on
the ones that want annual
one two one two three
three four five six that's not a
majority so we have a as a buying a
result
okay yes
just to make sure there's no confusion
there Ellen
to the opposition please I'll show of
hands for those those that were opposed
to annual
because it was only six in favor of
annual and then the other seven must be
in favor of buying you but he has raised
the issue that somebody might be
abstaining yeah
Ellen's called for a show of hands
against in
well and it falls
hang on slow down slow down slow down
gosh ring is going to have a meltdown
shortly I'll put the motion I'll put the
motion subject somebody seconding it
that we have it by annually and see if
we get a majority of that way so I'll
put the motion who's who's put the hand
up seeking there Barry thank you all
those in favor of bi-annual now raise
your hand
one two three four five six seven that's
the majority done every second year
folks
you've got two years to get the policy
together
what a long winter's Affair excuse me Mr
Mayor but could we now put number four
yes sorry so number one and four one so
we'll put one and four which is the uh
receiving of the report and the fact was
it the do we agree on the on the
community wellbeing fund subcommittee
I nominated it as the community
well-being committee and I seconded it
as the community well-being excellent so
just put those two motions in
one for all those in favor
aye Carrie
do you like to ask a question Marie
members in opposition for what recorded
as being away from the
subcommittee to the committee
it's not deletion of the word fund
holy crap
um right item 11.
yeah it's climate change I'm not going
to say anything on this
it's me again
um so
we this this paper speaks to the work
that the regional working group on
climate change the regional interagency
working group on climate change is doing
and we would have Workshop this last
week but both representatives of the
group deputy mayor and um councilor
Soper were not present so um this paper
is in lieu of that Workshop
um it's really an opportunity for you to
provide feedback at this halfway stage
in the process to developing a regional
climate change strategy which would be
consulted with the community on as part
of each council's long-term plan next
year
um so the intention of the regional
climate change principles and
aspirations are to form the past first
step of that strategy is to set the
general high-level Regional Direction
and this paper provides in the
attachment the paper that's been
developed by the regional interagency
working group as well as some points for
consideration in terms of the
implications for Council and moving in
this direction and just remind you that
we do support the regional working group
on climate change misalignment where
it's in alignment with the direction set
in the last long term plan and then
there will be the opportunity for this
Council to consider what actions it
specifically would want to take in
support of the strategy
um so I'm thought perhaps that the
deputy mayor and counselors open may
wish to speak on this matter
well I'll come in first and sorry I'll
comment first if you don't mind and
Leslie and Leslie Kim
um comment it looked there was a lot of
work went into this
um that group which
comprised as well as Leslie and I um two
representatives from each of the invite
each of the
um other Tas and environment Southland
um plus representatives from
um tomorrow
um and representatives I think
separately and I should just partner
tomorrow Monday probably separately
um for manafenua
um we had four meetings I think Leslie
if I remember correctly and there were
long meetings
um what you're looking at now as the
output of Art
and well it might look at first reading
as a bleeding obvious you know
the the reality was that we had to get
alignment across all four of those
councils to the wording
and commitment from each years that we
were prepared to you know recommend it
to our respective councils
so we had to get right as we could do
and as I said it was a lot of hard work
when any of the the wording I think it's
actually a very good
document as I say it might be bleeding
obvious but um so two of The Ten
Commandments
um and I I think that we can um as a
council
get behind us and then move it on now to
what we're going to do
yeah Leslie thank you
um what's the deputy mayor and and cheer
um Tom has Tom has given a good
description of how much hard work has
actually gone into this and they have
been long and intense discussion
meetings to reach this point and to do
the deputy mere full credit he has on a
number of occasions suggested that
um
this council could move earlier than the
2050 official Net Zero date and that
that would be open to any of the
councils but the fact is we we work long
and hard to reach a document that was
agreed by all the parties around that
table so that we could bring it back to
our respective councils in time for our
long-term plans and to and to move the
whole issue forward being very clear
about the need for Community
consultation and and further
communication with communities on the
way to reaching what is a pretty major
set of Net Zero statements
so it is
um I I totally agree with what the
deputy mayor has said it's a carefully
worded very comprehensive document and
we both recommend it to council
with the Proviso the council could
decide to move much more quickly
um and just a personal view from me
um I'm not sure this is the right
mechanism going forward
my view of this and it's reinforced by
the background information on page 78
I'm sorry on 70
on page 80 that climate change received
the lowest rating
in the surveys that were done and second
last ranking and the order of importance
of of 14 Regional issues and not and I
struggle with that because I hear it all
the time people know we've got to do
something in climate change but don't
know what we've got to do and when I
listen sometimes to the different voices
in our Council cluster
people are all running the walker in a
different direction so if this helps uh
give some strategic direction to that
that would be great my personal view is
that if we have a whichever government
we have post the election it would be
really sharp if
our regional councils environment
Southland took over not just the current
Suite of environmental issues that they
manage but also took over climate change
as well that would allow central
government to have a top-down system
which required those 14 Regional
councils throughout the country to give
some serious direction to where we need
to go and some of the work that we need
to do because it just seems to me when
you've got 67 councils working on a
bottom-up model and there's just no
consistency
but I do appreciate the work that's been
put in and it's way better than just us
sitting here by ourselves without having
our partners on board
so we have our Evelyn
so just to
reiterate tell madama was a full
participant at the table
and that's our regional environmental
entity
that includes those who set us Governors
at both
[Music]
um
environment Southland and myself here at
ICC I haven't personally appeared at
that I do it
as a governor in other in other manners
but having said that I don't think that
we can look at the results of a survey
on matters like this
and say well because it rated really
lowly it's not important to this Council
one of the reasons that I believe that
we are here is to show leadership
it's to actually sometimes to bring to
the Public's attention and to make
decisions that we know need to be made
whether or not the public actually
really recognizes that they need to be
made you're trusted to do these things
on behalf of the people that you
represent
um we don't always know what's best for
us
um we don't always recognize that having
a good night's sleep is a really good
idea when you're six and the light is
still shining outside but your mother
knows you need to get up and go to
school in the morning I am not comparing
the rate payers to a six-year-old what
I'm saying is that if you don't
understand what the implications to you
of this thing is why would you say it's
important but we can't say that we don't
know what the implications of climate
change are for the city we can't close
our eyes and we can't say
people aren't ready for this so
therefore we won't do it this is a thing
we need to discuss and decide because we
have got significant infrastructure that
we know will be impacted by sea level
rise within the foreseeable future and
when I say the foreseeable future less
than 50 years
less probably than 25 years if we don't
start making decisions now it will be
too late
and the cost to our community and the
pain that it will cause will be more
significant so whilst I understand the
purpose of surveys is an indicator of
what people are prioritizing sometimes
as Leaders we actually have to say
we recognize that this isn't the top of
your list but is the responsible
Trustees of your assets
and the future of this community we are
drawing this not only to your attention
but we are making this a significant
priority for your Council table
and we'll receive your grateful thanks
in the future
because this is the hard stuff this is
not the easy stuff this is where the
rubber hits the road if you like in
terms of governance
so I am grateful that
um
for the leadership that everybody has
shown for the very hard work that has
been put into this for the clarity that
is displayed and I'm sorry but I believe
whichever
[Music]
um
iteration of governance we have at
central government climate change and
adaptation and
investment is not going to go away and
we as a council can't be any different
we need to bite the bullet and just get
on with it thank you for that ringy
um this takes me back to the vaccine
mandate
um I'd like to actually see some real
science and the fact that there's no
doubt the sea level rights okay that has
proven but if we're if we're going to
make decisions in a governance role we
don't want to be going off on tangents
on personal beliefs and whatever look
we would don't want to act like frantic
people who are trying to save the planet
without without sensible science and now
fair enough the sea level is rising that
is proven fact but we also need the
science around what else is happening in
the weather patterns and everything so
sorry I like you know this this sort of
sitting around
uh with a guitar singing Kumbaya I'm not
into that at all sorry
wow so can I come in look I think
it would be absolutely negligent of us
as a governance group
to say that we simply don't believe that
we're going to wait until the water's a
lapping taste rate before we're going to
believe that climate change is happening
that would be ABS that would be
absolutely a dead election of our duties
we we have got to be that the things
that need to be done are things that
will be literally intergenerational you
know things like building up stock Banks
and so forth it's going to happen
probably over the next 50 years
and we've got to start planning for that
and if we say let's wait until you know
we have absolute proof with our own eyes
literally what a lap in tertiary if
we're going to wait until then then
um we would run out of time we'd no
longer be able to respond to it sorry to
you I just need to say that I
acknowledge sea level rise as a problem
I wish the other member would actually
listen and no we're not going to have
any more comments on that thank you from
either party
um Leslie
the matter of the so-called low ranking
on a survey and just point out
that often surveys depend on what is
included in them
some of the other choices in Rhiannon
will probably be able to fill in all 14
but if you are faced with housing
transport climate change and several
other issues is regional issues it is
very likely oh and the other one would
be alternative water sources it is very
likely that air air population might
very well choose housing and transport
the roads that they are
walking on or driving their vehicles on
as more top priority issues because they
are more immediate in the mind
and
is perhaps perceived that we've got more
time on climate change
the reality is that the group that the
deputy mayor and I have been on has had
a great deal of scientific data
presented to us there is a great deal
more that environment Southland is
sourcing at the present time which is
why there are not some more scientific
statements in the material than there
might have been if all the lidar data
Etc was available but the fact is
we have jointly agreed as the re as a
region that we have a serious climate
change issue that we are all prepared to
agree on principles to address
we are a Long Way Forward from where we
were 10 or 15 years ago
I agree that we
do not wait until we have the um
the refugees
fighting in the streets to get away from
the water that is coming towards us but
at least around this table everybody has
actually agreed that sea levels are
rising
if we can all agree on that can we
please get back to the principles of
this document which is we have an issue
it is a global issue it is a regional
issue we have all Air Regional players
agreeing
on a document to start actually
seriously addressing it and seriously
putting it into our long-term plans so I
urge you to get away from the is climate
change real implications
and actually look at what this document
is saying regionally we actually have a
regional agreement let's go for it thank
you Harry
yeah sorry I don't agree with you Leslie
I I don't agree with climate change at
all I think we're chucking a lot of
money
it's something that unless you can prove
to me and just show me documents then I
might start believing it but
I don't believe for a second at the
moment well there goes Buzz Lightyear
just gonna get slowly now
I'm Darren
hey give me a clerk and therein lies the
Beauty and the burden of democracy
I understand and respect the two
councilors who have said that they
will subscribe to sea level rise
but climate change
is more than that and and councilor
pottinger used the vaccination issue and
in some senses there are some real
similarities in in
selected facts that put forward from
either sides so that's why it's up to us
I think through this process to to look
at at reliable
uh science someone will always find on
the amazing internet
um
some information that will that will be
to the contrary the bottom line is
change is happening and it includes some
significant change and around weather
patterns there's a whole lot of people
in the North Island at the moment whose
lives are severely affected and will be
for some time because of a significant
weather event now the thing is they
always happened accepted
but they are happening more frequently
and that's the concern and when you see
the feedback that the citizens of the
world
including our young people will it keeps
saying that we're building the world for
March in our streets to say can you
please be aware of this
I'd like to be one of those that says
yeah we're listening but
let's go through and and democratically
come to a resolution as a council
bearing in mind that with the council it
can hold their own views
so just a quick reflection for me before
we go to some others do you want to
speak
um I think Leslie raised an interesting
issue on two points
if we'd run the same survey in Gisborne
as opposed to raising it here I think
climate change would have been the top
item not the 14th and the other issue
which I think is just listening to what
I hear away from this table
um our biggest risk is probably flooding
as opposed to see your eyes and we don't
have the leader data which we want which
is coming through environmental health
and with that we'll know where our risks
are in in relation to Rivers expanding
and flowing into our cities and
townships and there's a lot of creative
work going on here so that will
certainly help
thank you Mr meal I just wanted to
um
support what councilor Leslie sofa said
actually one of the
um looking through the information that
we've been provided with it is very
extensive but I also want to note that
fifth form School geography we were
taught there that there are two with the
pins in this country learning and El
Nino we were taught various things from
um that were actually based on school
suits forget they were actually
scientifically proven I think
we're seeing intensification of climate
behavior and I think that our youth
Council sat here weeks ago telling us
how they had dealt with that Vision that
they wanted us to pick up the reins and
look after their future for them work
and Harmony working in the journey
together and I think it's imperative to
us to show leadership to not be ignorant
but actually to open our minds up and
know that something's not always going
to be the same way year after year and
we look at the floods here we look at
the floods of the North Island we look
at the devastation that has happened
with
um those natural disasters and the
depleting way that lives livelihoods
families have been halted so yes I do
agree that when a survey is presented to
our rate pass often it is they can't
make the connection as to what they
physically see feel in touch if that's
ever had been perhaps targeted in in
things that they could connect with as
being climate change
um we could have had a very different
outcome most of our ratepayers are up a
certain age
bracket that
um this is mind-boggling for them so yes
we do have to show leadership
irrespective of what your personal
belief is there is evidence to say that
things are happening and that we need to
mitigate for these
it was a bit harsh talking about your
school years and remembering guys
remember going to school first six
sevens then you've got Messi then
University there's so much science that
we can't ignore it
are you
all right
um
I'm sort of in um the one thing we've
been talking about climate change really
probably only for the last 20 or 30
years and it's you know there's been a
lot of
scheme angering going on and um you know
the the fact that young people now speak
out about it is because of older people
uh the rhetoric that they've been
announcing for the last few years now
I'm not denying that there is climate
change but I believe that there has
always been climate change I mean we
live on a ball that goes around the sun
I don't have to explain that to
everybody and it can wobble it can move
it can wobble over time I mean air time
of reporting weather is such a short
time in actual global history if you
like that we seem to think that we have
made such a huge impact on it because
there's nine you know seven and a half
or eight nine billion of us now when I
was born there was only two and a half
billion people in the world now there's
eight or nine billion people so in my
lifetime the population has changed like
that nobody really talks about that um
the fact that there's a massive amount
of pollution in the world nobody talks
about that they all talk about climate
change now the climate has always
changed
and it always will continue to change
because of the nature of nature now if
we're going to build sort of houses and
low-lying Beach you know Beach areas
well obviously they are going to be at
risk of rising tides
I mean I sort of agree with rangi I
agree with Barry I agree with the people
that are sitting on the on these
committees
but
in fear I also believe that the 24 of
people that are mentioned on the uh in
the poll um also um
it's not a high priority for a lot of
people it's not a high priority to me I
don't think we're going to have make any
impact on it whatsoever we have such a
small as a country but we're just on
such a small
contributor to the to the carbon thing
of the world
yet we all think that we're going to do
something marvelous here and change
everything we're not going to change
anything the best thing we could
probably do is don't let people build
houses in low
at sea level I mean but we still do
and I I don't understand that there's
something that we could change we could
make a difference anything else that we
do we're going to make no difference
we are so so small but we imagine
ourselves to be so big and that's what's
happened to the whole world
we all you know we all think that we you
know
in this
everything's just changed but it's been
changing forever and it always will
continue to change I mean I believe one
volcano eruption does more damage to the
atmosphere and the ozone layer with um a
carbon block out then um probably
running cars everybody driving cars for
like 10 years
and I think that the the fact that
everybody talks about it is just because
the scare magnet that's going on by
older people talking about it
it's not such a scary thing it's just a
fact of life
so I don't know where my conversation is
going though
just giving you a bit of a yeah
so I've got some other people online
trash
oh moving on
I think this is one thing one place
where we have to show strong leadership
is some of my colleagues have said
it's absolutely a no-brainer and you
know councilor I have it without cancer
we didn't try and make change
but nothing would happen it's a
beautiful story about throwing a
starfish back into the sea I do believe
that we have to do the peace that we
care and we have to show to our
community that we are the leaders they
asked us to be
whatever it is and then the other key
thing for me is the fact that the whole
Regional Council is on this path
together
and I really do believe that we need to
take some action from here
Tom
um two things flown from Alan's comments
I I wanted to comment on I the first one
was I think actually Alan captured it
perfectly when he said you know I kind
of agree with everybody because nobody's
a hundred percent sure yeah it's just a
reality I'm gonna say I'm 100 sure that
climate change is happening but I must
admit my belief in terms of probability
has gone up if you'd asked me 10 years
ago I would have probably said there was
one chance in 10. no I think it's
probably seven chances in ten so you
know I but nobody knows absolutely for
sure like I I don't know absolutely for
sure that my house is going to burn down
but still insured against that happening
I take action today by Tina insurance
policy because it will happen and I
think the probability is high enough now
that we've got to take out that kind of
insurance policy the other thing Alan
said that I want to come in on is
um you know we hope in the one hand
mitigation and we have adaptation
mitigation is reducing our carbon
dioxide emissions that is a national
thing we play a part in that but a role
is very small I agree on Ural is very
small but in terms of adaptation
nobody's going to do it except us right
so protecting the city from flooding
whether it comes from heavier rainfall
or whether it comes from Rise and sea
levels nobody's going to do that that
will be a council accountability our
combined council's accountability and I
think you'll find that the bulkhead of
what this team now moves towards will be
in that area lidar for example that's
about adaptation
what that we have to do as a council to
protect the city mitigation should we'll
do things I mean I think air carbon
dioxide emissions what was it 14 000
tons
is that a call Rhiannon
um
I'll Trust your recollection right I
think it's 14 000 tons that's not a lot
we could fix up frankly so that is not
going to be the main body what main body
of work is going to be protect and city
in terms of you know stop Banks maybe
even sea walls or whatever but it's all
doable but it takes a long time and
unless you're starting out we're going
to run out of time yeah so before I um
give to Alice a bit of a speak on this
um you're right Tom
um I don't always agree with things
relating to gore but they've actually
got the head around this so good example
of that for me was when we were at a
recent mural Forum they said that the
lighter leader information will tell
them where their pressure points are on
the rivers depending on how much water
you put on the rivers either from the
sky or from the mountains and it was
very interesting they said well why do
we keep building bigger stop Banks
because all it does is just move the
volume somewhere else why don't we have
stop Banks North of Gore that as we see
them getting to critical points we we
intentionally breach the stop bag and
let the water run onto a couple of
thails we're going to do some damage but
far better than running into the main
streets of war and I just thought that
was really proactive way of doing it
adaptation and they're the opportunities
I think we should look for so two more
speakers
um and I'll give you the final one
Leslie senior on that committee
um so pania
oh Tom actually just sort of like hit
the nail on the head but I just wanted
to support don't keep agreeing with him
it's not healthy
no we are no totally support
um the report that's been put before us
I think the aspirations
um and the principals that have been
well thought out and I totally support
and happy just moving forward in some
way or form because it's like
uh Ria said you know we we need to show
leadership in this this area and it's
it's something that has been packed for
a long time
just as you reflect basically on your
final speech to this group
um
the recommendation the second
recommendation up there is to provide
feedback on the craft the winning are
considering is that something you do you
and Tom do or is that something that
Rhiannon does or both and what sort of
feedback would we get because we had
quite a diverse conversation around this
table
I think you can pretty well pick up
where the general thrust was going from
most people well the three of us are
attendees and your representatives at
the Joint meeting so I'm sure between
the three of us we can feed back a
balanced view in the decision that
Council will come to yeah yeah
so was that it from you or oh okay
I was merely answering yeah that's okay
so I've got this order
so having having heard from a number of
counselors around the table I am sorely
tempted to play the devil Ed Devil's
Advocate and start an argument that in
fact the Earth is flat
however
I am is there a signature
I am a responsible counselor and I'm
going to go I am going to I'm going to
go back to the actual point of what we
are dealing with here
um and and really just reiterate the
comments that the deputy mayor and I
have made a great deal of work has gone
into this weekend as a council play a
significant role in moving this issue
forward
via is absolutely no doubt that the
balance of evidence
is weighted in favor of us needing to do
that
um in my case I would go further than
Deputy mirror and say that I am 100
convinced of the reality
um however the weight the weight of
evidence is clearly at the point where
we have no choice on this issue we have
the entire region agreeing on this and
I'll just refer Mr Mayor to what you
have said that Gore
um has
admittedly themselves moved Leaps and
Bounds to be in a position where where
they uh
a very on board part of this Coalition
who sees that we have the need to
actually progress this for the good of
air communities and future I'll just
make one more reference to that survey
that was mentioned
the highest ranking
issues on that survey were issues like
housing and transport all of which have
significant climate change factors in
where we are with them today reference
has been made to where we actually build
houses in the future
to our need for more stock Banks to
weather some of their roads are in the
right places and perhaps we're going to
have to face the reality of some shifts
in our whole transport Network in the
future but all those top ranking issues
had climate change implications and
serious considerations as part of them
so it's not a simple matter of saying
climate change right ranked 14. it's a
matter of saying what were the climate
change implications of every issue that
was on that survey
we've now got an agreed Regional plan
for how we can actually move this issue
to the benefit of our community and I
really urge this Council to make it a
unanimous agreement that we received
with support and move forward
thank you
so just as the last reflection before I
put the motion
I think when I listen to the discussions
um
I can understand where those that are
opposed to mitigation come from
so long as we struggle to get to carbon
Zero by whenever so long as Brazil
America China and India are doing the
damage they're doing we will never get
there but as Tom quite rightly said we
do have significant options because we
seem to be light on damage at the moment
to do a lot of adaptation which is to
look for opportunities when we can
reduce our risk of the impact that the
global players don't get there
so I think that that goes for me a
possible way forward that we don't just
throw our energy at one particular issue
that doesn't uh doesn't lead in Lincoln
and look for options like the gore
option of the leader information and see
where the potential is
so two motions in front of us or two
recommendations some would like to put
both
Leslie and Tom thank you very much
you did say yes yeah
all those in favor
aye aye carried
all right the next
Okay so we've got I'm told that we have
to have a toilet break now for a
10 minutes so
and cup of tea
all right welcome back from that short
break
okay so next item on on the uh
on the agenda is your remuneration
reallocation
so for those that are still talking Alex
um this is taking the
portion of the remuneration that we had
with Nigel skelt before he departed and
now re-shifting in it
we've had a um we've collected we had a
council's only meeting on this issue
which gave us a bit of a Stairway we
wanted to go with that but to my mistake
I didn't realize that the
amount of money that will remuneration
we're giving Grant actually pushed him
slightly higher than Tom and the deputy
mayor's role so that's created a bit of
discussion so um but I've spoken to both
Grant and Tom and so I guess I just want
to affirm with the two other
you falling apart Peter my name is oh
yeah um just confirm with Darren and
with Randy that they're still happy
about the issues that we discussed
previously about the level that
that project team lead would go up to I
think the climate change discussion
might change that sorry I didn't care
today
no it's okay um
he's running a temperature who said
yes I was I wasn't aware that uh
um I mean I'm quite supportive of
options
well I've spoken to Tom and to Grant as
well and Tom doesn't have an issue with
it
um and I personally don't have an issue
where they're giving it it's a um
level of the remuneration is specific to
the the museum project and I know that
Darren you have a lot of work and
District licensing and rangi has it also
in wastenet as well or waste
minimization or whatever
um that the extra rolls that come on top
but the project is a very big big
commitment of time
um so I guess the impact was really for
you too
you don't mind
okay anybody else want to have some
discussion about the options that are
put in front of us by Michael
Leslie yeah
I
um I also just want to say that it's so
unusual to have any remuneration of any
other
office holder going higher than the
deputy Mia I just find that
uncomfortable and
in very unusual
if it's a conscious decision for Council
to do that
Council has the ability to do that I I
just I just find it an unusual thing
to make a decision that would lead to
that effect I mean a deputy mayor is
there and respected as being there
for a whole host of responsibilities for
which they are given a higher
remuneration than other members of
council because of the role there for
filling
I just think of
I just looked at Option One and thought
that is a very unfortunate consequence
sure
yes and and therefore either we in my
mind either we preferred option two or
we came up with another
adjustment
that didn't lead to that effect
Alex
um thank you your worship
um
okay thank you me and Nobby thank you
it's a
is this a Heather I'm sorry yeah
um
my inclination is toward option two
um not too dissimilar to what uh Council
Cipher has just said but also that um
taking into account that there are many
um advisory boards and bits and pieces
that we set on as well as subcommittees
that were appointed to that as
councilors we're not actually you know
remuner remunerated over and above four
but yet conduct consider about
considerable more work I suppose on a
baseline And I think looking at
councilor Soper herself you know like
she's appointed to quite a few of our
additional commitments and doesn't
receive any additional base remuneration
um absolutely empathize with the huge
amount of work that Grant is taking on
board for us and I think that the five
thousand dollar on top of his
um chairmanship is considerably more
Equitable than
um superseding the deputy mere
Maria
okay me yeah sorry Mr Man um Michael
just reading your mind that you wanted
to say something no I thought you said
Marina
who is this
it's on Stingray
you're in trouble right so I guess a lot
of this was pre
um discussed while I was away on holiday
and I'd had looked at these at option
one and two and um for me um option one
wasn't an attractive offer
um option two leaning more towards but
that's because in my mind when you
structured at this Council the lead role
project 2025 was one Soul counselor with
no tier position because that's how it
was prioritized that they only focus on
that one project to get it across the
line to make sure that we have
everything possible leave us there to to
balance our budgets or what have you
um and super
um seating that grants also a tier to
the finance and project committee my my
kind of gut feeling was is that Grant
needs needed additional support I know
realize it's outside of this actual
document and I mentioned that to the
mere uh previous to the council meeting
today
um
I think for me as a counselor and yes
going on to a subcommittee and doing
more work I'm not here we're dulling up
the money
and that's just my personal opinion
um
I feel that
um we're voting on giving ourselves
potentially a bit of a pay rise and it
feels uncomfortable doing that
it really does but a decision has to be
made so
I mean I'm leaning more towards option
two but I know that Tom comes up with
these equations
at times
um that seem to be more fairer and
um more appropriate and I just wonder
if there's such an equation that we can
give and make an option three from
any further discussion
I won't drag Tom or Grant into this
all right we do have an option I can
leave this paper sitting on the table to
our next meeting because the impacts can
always be backdated and ask Michael to
go away and try and I guess get some
more realignment between the Project
Lead and the deputy in Israel
I mean that's that's not hard to do
so that has the blessing
then there's we're all leaving and we
just come back at the next meeting
because it's not urgent but we do have
to use the money
otherwise we have one huge um
drinkies at Christmas time
so it disappears
yeah so I'm happy to do that and ask
Michael to just tweak the figures a
little bit again happy to do that Mr Man
thank you yeah okay with that Tom
yeah look I mean I wasn't going to come
in as I said to you Mr mid and I I don't
mean at all if the numbers fall in a
position where you know Granny earns
more than me
um I I did do a healthy view which I
will express since you've invited me to
um I I think when Nigel was appointed to
that project Lee it was an abasis that
he had no other promoted position and it
would have been quite unreasonable to
ask me to take on that volume of work or
so any remuneration at all
um I I think as I look at the chairs
um you know done and has numerous rules
at commutative
um the committee of the heat shares and
um the the the the work it's done by
rangi particularly see in westnet
you know the chairs do take on Project
work which is assumed to be embedded in
their
um chair remuneration
so I in my view if each year had been
asked to be the project lead on the
museum
I don't think we would have agreed to
having a ten thousand dollar
um additional payment if that had been
the case we would have said look it's
embedded in the chairs allowance
so coming to the situation we're facing
the reality as it did actually have a
um an allowance for Nigel which was
completely appropriate
um I don't think it's appropriately
completely extinguished that with
respect to
um the role that Grant now fills because
even just by personal experience in the
last couple of days I can see how deeply
embedded Granite is in the you know any
Museum project and you know how much
work he's he's doing in that area
um but nevertheless I think it's also
reasonably argue that it is a project
and he has project chair and therefore
you could say partially remunerated for
that already so if I had a button tea
press I'd probably base press option two
button
um has been you know fear we have done
it
um but let's see if we did end up but I
don't really agree with artificial way
idea I don't want anything done just to
make sure I'm a dollar high on granted
and like that I mean that isn't the
issue at all
um so I like I would I would support
option two maybe there's another option
three certainly if we were going to
option two I would
um propose a five thousand dollar split
the Grant and the remainder is split
equally between the
um equally between all other councilors
maybe we could kick it any touch and see
make or go away and look at other
options
I don't know what other options are that
I mean you end up with two subs one
third year I mean
I don't know there's any there's any
particularly logical way we end up we
just have to fix that number
I won't put you on the spot Grant but I
won't give you the opportunity okay
any further discussion now on uh yeah I
just agree with time I think it's just a
simple just
do a vote now I don't think the thing
you need an option three
the option one or option two well if one
of you will move option two we might
have a vote
I'll move option two yeah I'll second it
um I'm gonna take some advice for a
minute
thank you
okay so just a bit of technicality there
so before we move or accept the Mover
and the second note I'm going to move
that option one changes to Michael
giving us a further option so what we'll
be voting on is either option two which
is sitting in front of you or we go back
to Michael for an extra the option one
doesn't kick in because if two doesn't
get over the line we default back to one
if you understand what I'm saying
so I'll move that way that option one
changes to seeking some further advice
if somebody would like to seek on that
trash all those in favor
sure yeah
I actually don't quite understand what
you just said are we voting for option
two no no if if I leave the two options
in front of us and option two doesn't
get over the line one will what I'm
saying is what I'm picking up around the
room is that the two preferred options
we would like in front of us is option
two which is currently sitting here all
going back for Michael to tweak things
as opposed to option one that's an
amendment to the resolution
yeah
so
hey not a motion just an amendment yeah
it's just an amendment at this stage
yeah because I think you would need to
put option two first Mr Mia and then if
that has lost the amended option one
would follow okay then we'll do that
then
so who are the original movies
and uh councilor Arnold okay put the
Motions for option two
all those a favor
is there any opposition that we need to
be aware of
option two it is
well done
yeah
before we do project 1225
um we're just gonna do the last one the
Open Session which is the issue of the
amendment to the government statement
it was just a point Steve to all the
jobs that we don't want
sorry Mr Manchester and uh there is an
additional a recommendation that needs
to be made just to amend the delegation
to register
um just to reflect that the community
well-being fund uh is having an
additional person added to its number by
uh councilor board's appointment to that
so that is just a number five showing
there I didn't changes from five to six
and that just confirms that councilor
board is appointed to the infrastructure
committee the community wellbeing
committee and I'm noticing that there's
a Capital C in a lowercase C but that's
okay we'll tidy that up Community
well-being fund and is taking the place
uh into the invocable public art gallery
and further to that the conversation
that we've had earlier today
um appointing councilors sopa and bond
to be the portfolios of CCTV
um for that time
so I have an another
um part of that as well that in the
community wellbeing fund the deputy me
is currently in there and he would like
to come away from that acknowledging
that Steve replaces him and we still to
have the two alternates there as well
that's perfect in that case uh Mr Mayor
I would withdraw number five that does
not need to be there because the number
of counselors does not change so we will
and I will withdraw number five
and we'll make that adjust um that
change that Council board comes in for
Deputy mere gamble so just for your
benefit Trish
um does that create you any issues with
one off and and too old and it's on
so Steve comes on in place of Tom so
it's like for like and you have two
alternates here as well I don't see it
doesn't seem to be a problem no okay
it's just a wonderful clarification sure
I don't see Council abroad's name being
proposed against the community
well-being funded no that was um that
was a
there was a clerical error when the
information came through to me and I
missed that in my report I am doing that
today when I was advised that that was
the intention so that is why you're
seeing it and the resolutions in front
of you that as an oral update because it
came after the major late item had
already been prepared and I didn't want
to do a major 8 out and major late item
oh I apologize because
um
I wasn't looking at the year I was
looking at my screen so thank you but
can I just suggest that you correct word
receives
yes the computer doesn't like it is the
IPM yeah
and accept and receive another
clarification for you Michael
um that Steve's
um role on ipag he doesn't like either
he's replaces Barry Barry yes yeah and
also that I'm not listed as being an
alternative pool Bluff to Bluff
Community Council
I'm reasonably certain we have done that
we have I'm pretty sure we've done it if
that change hasn't come through I
apologize it will be correct because it
has been done
uh so just for your benefits Steve
um
infrastructure and Community well-being
uh uh the core of our business I guess
uh risk and assurance and finance and
projects are
more peripheral committees I guess not
most of where it works down so it's a
bit of a learning curve you best to be
on those two as opposed to the alternate
and I assumed subject to you nodding at
me in the next couple of minutes that
you would be happy to be on the
well-being fund which is a distribution
of thumbs out to community groups and
that you'd have an interest in the uh
public art gallery which has some
ongoing work about where that will
actually sit in the next year or two
excellent
Ria is going to say something
I can just tell
oh you went
excellent sorry you worship did
counselor Stewart say he wanted to be
removed as the one of the alternates for
the bluff community board no no no no
no
she she's gonna she's gonna say
something isn't she yeah sorry Mr Mia is
this where I um
uh like to uh request that I go on to
the finance and projects committee
um as soon as how we're doing a bit of
tidying up
yeah I don't have any opposition to that
um I don't have any obligation to that
we tend to be light on that committee
anyway aren't we grow up yep we'll add
that on of grunts there's an additional
recommendation from me because I knew
that was coming yes so you're happy to
uh have on the committee group okay yeah
yeah that's all cool
[Laughter]
sorry just one more Amendment
um
Council abroad has indicated that he'd
also like to be an alternate for youth
Council he came along to our meeting
last week and I believe
um so we've currently got you Darren and
Alex
a third person okay or does it
complicate things okay
thank you
so as I said at the beginning of time
these appointments need to be uh places
where you feel good about working not
just quoting of public knowledge the
work that
rangi does on wasting it'll waste
minimization and a CCTV which is been
talking about for about six or seven
years now
and the extensive work that we do out in
the community Through you Leslie and
through you there
so I'll put those uh series of motions a
series of amendments
which I think I can do anyway Kevin
yeah
this process of the boat is not um it's
not approving the appointments it's just
a meaning the
statement yep so all those in favor I
in the opposition no that was your
chance to get out Grant
where am I getting out to where's Rhea
yeah
carried
so now we have project 1225.
um
do you want to take this
yeah because we can shoot this way
thank you everyone welcome gentlemen and
Lee
afternoon all
um just to be a little bit um time
precious because
um Road needs to be on a flight back up
to Auckland so I wouldn't mind through
you Mr Mayor if we can address the
naming a little bit earlier in this
report sure
um just to allow do that right now if
you like perfect but I love to just the
um lovely gentleman with me so on my on
my left is RO Hoskins from design tribe
who leads uh the cultural elements of
1225.
and to my right uh Cameron curd who
looks after uh our Museum sort of
technical expertise and is leading our
experience Pace as well
okay
so if you all benefit Lee I can move
recommendation four now if you want to
just want to clear that up okay so quick
discussion around that we've had a
counselor only session as well where
we've tried to narrow down what the
naming of the museum would be
um we got to the stage where the advice
from Erie was that murihika was not
appropriate because it's wider context
so it had to be sell them from my end I
just wanted the word Museum in there so
that it has its ID and te'anua is a
previous
um title has been given the names of the
museum so it seems to sit well
um yeah I'm coming to Iran
um so the issue I I guess is we've got
two options here but I will open up the
discussion if you want to about the
those two options are also ringing
just just um through email is we have
provided a um a presentation pack if the
councilors would prefer to go through
that pack uh and uh row could take us
through that uh if that would be helpful
for the counselors to go through but
they're naming yes
um I think we have quite a robust debate
at the council only issues we went
across
a lot of that I'll come to that if we
need it yeah look
um
key thing is
uh to papa is
and it's Museum of New Zealand um with
the with the trail name there and and I
I believe we have to try our name first
but Museum of Southland gives an
ownership
uh using the word of and I believe
that's critical and also looking at the
te Papa design is that I think we move
as quick as we can
to create a brand a logo whatever you
like to call it
something that we can use both in uh and
columns and marketing and everything I
don't know whether that's I talked to
Grant about it he wasn't aware that
anything was was underway but it like
it's one of these things you've got to
get it right first time and obviously in
1998 to Papa I don't know how much this
cost but I think it was a few dollars to
get a thumbprint but it's really
important I I believe it will give the
whole project some real identity
um once we I mean we didn't even wear
the T-shirt if we can get something done
like this so that's I mean I'm all keen
on the Museum of Southland but I'm also
very keen that we move on on a brand on
on a logo on a whatever you call it sure
Leslie thank you Mr Beer um I am of the
country opinion I actually prefer 4B te
anua Southland Museum largely because
it is my belief that the of will be
dropped
almost immediately and people will defer
to it being tienua Southland Museum and
I can't see why we would add in the the
extra word just for it to be popularly
dropped from then onwards so my
preference is the simpler form of 4B and
I was happy to move that way when the
discussion gets to that point yeah
at all so actually Evelyn's at hand off
the edges so you might take a long time
great
um thank you Tom for your courtesy
um the my renuka supported Museum of
Southland once we were asked to import
into that option as well so not that it
carries any more weight than anybody
else but we did quite like the rhythm of
it
um however democracy will prevail the
thing that we are happiest about is that
we seem to have come to a place where to
inua is no longer
um
the Target and we're now looking at what
the English version is and deciding on
that so with that in mind
um I'm not uncomfortable with counselor
sopa's opinion but representing
um our our opinion it was Museum of
South and kyota
Tom
uh interesting that Evelyn brought up
the question of Rhythm of the name
because I actually also support Museum
of Southland because actually
grammatically it means to a new Museum
of Southland would be a single name
rather than two separate names
wouldn't it because grammatically it
actually forms itself whereas to a newer
Southern Museum
um it's clearly two separate things so I
I feel very
trash I think it's just you know your
personal preference I find the rhythm of
do you know a Southern Museum as one
line
which is contrary to what Thomas is and
contrary to what evidence is so I'm
happy either way but I prefer
um option
yeah
um I'll make this out very unpopular
again
um I'm gonna go for B but I think the
should be certain Museum first
started that many times yep
um Ella I'll come to your team in a
minute Lee I support her I think tenua
Museum of Southern I think that that
means that the Torio name will be used
more often I think because it's uh yeah
yeah
it's a museum itself and so if you like
to buffer yeah because we don't we talk
about Department
Museum of New Zealand you don't say that
all right so it's called to Papa nothing
yeah newer will be eventually what's
used
yeah totally oh transparency
um before I come to your team Lee uh no
secret that I have had some more
position to some of the wording in the
past about English first ulterior first
um I uh quite liked the option A it does
flow the other issue for me is the
Museum of Southall implies it is a
museum of Southland as opposed to a
Southland Museum because Southland
Museum implies that Southland are
actually running the museum and and
definitely they are not doing that this
is definitely a city museum run on
behalf of of The Wider southen group so
I prefer a and I really like the our
ability to be able to um
as you say run with the branding of it
because I think The Branding will really
pick up but the important thing is to
also know
um what the total name means and the
fact that the museum word is in there it
just tells people it's a museum and then
you use the other
three hour party branding and I'm quite
paper of that
yeah Peter yeah whichever way we go I
believe
that most people in the future will
probably just refer to it as a Southern
Museum I believe the
you know uh will be possibly
there but won't be used
so I believe
that the South Museum was what people
will refer to the museum is so I go
along with Barry yep it's okay
and I think when I look at I did a
survey last week of
what the government agencies do driven
on the advice from T puny cookery and
it's all over the place
um like the police have a double barrel
name but it's always pleased
um MSD is the same even though they have
Tyrion names but then the others the
other way around
and I think if I look at the formal
paper that comes out of the national
museum it does say the national museum
of New Zealand and then it says to Papa
underneath
but having said that everybody's
gravitated towards te Papa because
they've done some really clever
marketing
and and so the whole idea of a double
barrel name is one marketing but as long
as you know what the building you're
marketing actually is which is a museum
then you've got a double barrel win so
your team's chance for some input if you
want to Lee
um yeah I'd like to open the floor up to
um road to maybe just talk a little bit
about how we got there
um I'm a designer's point of view yeah
thank you um yeah I think uh in the the
brief that we received as the design
team the the uh notion of the te onua
um was uh quite compelling in as the
council will know a big part of our
design response has been responding to
the geography of
um of Southland including the uh the
Antarctic islands and and uhuda and um
we we felt that to create a
um a design which honored that name in
The partnership that's embedded in that
name was actually a really important
thing to do to bring the community
together and also to remember that all
of the arrivals to this particular area
and like and people keep arriving it's
not just a historical construct it's a
continual place of arrival
um so as it are just on behalf of the
design team we're very pleased to have
um the notion of the unua embedded in
the brief and to responders we have and
so far
um it appears that the designers has had
some reasonable level of support for the
people who've seen it and that's always
encouraging uh for us as a design team
thank you Phil
so uh Ria
I I do like both names I'm really
pleased that while I've been away that
there has been a talk for seven percent
in the council and to Illinois is um and
sitting there it flows off my tongue
naturally option b um but I see the
significance of saying to una to unawa
Museum of Southland I do see that as
being more significant than option b so
in that context I'd be going to a sure
because yeah
South Museum did fly off my my time as
well but
but I think when I look at it as a whole
museum sort of sticks out comfortably
for me
um and I'm really Rec we're here
moving forward yeah Tom and then I go to
Darren he's the last uh you know the
risk of you know maybe some order from
Ponyo Evelyn
um and maybe others I mean do we need
two names in the center do we need to
get hyphen but not hyphen we've got a
whatever you call our vertical line
um I mean can we not simply call it to a
new Museum of Southland Canada just be a
single name I mean it is that actually
kind of
both of those the language too much I
mean not my client can I just speak on
this specific thing I mean thank you um
I think we're getting away too far ahead
of ourselves and we're considering
things like that the atom and the reason
I say that is because it will all depend
on how the brand application comes out
so much like um you've got te Papa
Museum of New Zealand it'll depend on
you know different brand implications as
to which leads for what application but
for the majority I think you're quite
right it could be a comma in some cases
or it could be a dash in some cases or
in some applications it may just be the
Standalone tenua on its own so I think
yeah I think I mean I don't want to get
used to so many single men seems better
than having a name in one scene than
even the other sea yeah yeah
uh before I give you the last last word
right there oh before I give Steve the
second the last so much good stuff said
at my smile because it's obviously right
of all a different different opinion I
think the Rhythm I like simple bold
clear when it comes to marketing and
your right marketing is going to be so
key to this uh so I go for option b to
unawa South museum with the hope you
know opposing or different to Peter that
with the hope that people would would
use to unawa simple it's a pie to Papa
there
um
to show how the process works I came
along here with an opinion and have
changed it so
I mean the meeting today
um I was supportive of option b uh
because it was concise
um it also reflected uh the previous
name it wasn't the
Museum and art gallery of Southland
South Museum and art company
then I had what I hope I'd like
okay
I'll go with that
I'm happy to hear their voice
so back to your team
um and just a brief question on the
naming so if we went with that option A
I mean I personally would like there to
be one name
that line not to have a differentiation
which sort of implies given that we've
given that the names that we're using
The Toria names we're using are
metaphoric
so they they're not they're not a
statement that says into Rio this is a
museum
or south of Museum it's something
completely different around the double
Hull Walker I'll come back there
um so I'd be interested to know whether
your view of that would be that we just
have a single line which says te anoa
Museum of Southern
I mean very important to the name yeah
I'm agnostic on on the A and the B
yeah
Alex
um thank you Alisha um
respectfully I would I would like to
request that we leave this to The
Experts when it comes to Brand
application and marketing I I would soon
rather see us in much what councilor
pottinger has said to see to get um the
ball rolling on what the brand
application will look like so we can see
it and then make that decision there we
don't know what we're voting on you
don't you don't want to hamstring the
designers when it comes to how they have
to form the identity for this project
by saying it must still be in in one
line like I think we should leave it up
to them didn't suggest that what I was
saying is that the name could just be
that the name could be the the five if
you're looking at a the five words are
actually in there there's no slash mark
in between that differentiates between
to Rio and English you just have the one
brand if it's shortened down for marking
purpose that's great because a lot of
places do exactly that
they take a a shortened version that
means uh it's much better to Market
yeah I think we can stop on semantics of
there being a dash in between it I don't
think that's I think that's just to show
a differentiation between the two names
it's not saying that it's actually going
to have a big slash in between it when
it comes to design application
correct yes
Evelyn's Beauty actually having the
single
rule what's because it does there is a
mixture there which I actually quite
like but it may be offensive I don't
know
um I personally don't think brand
experts should be deciding the name of
the museum that's a tail wagging the dog
I love you I think you're going to name
an inlet Club Brandy expensive because I
mean I normally cork I mean we're not
going to want marketless Museum
but I'd be really interested in England
well if you'd like my view I like to and
I there and I would like we see as
myself and underneath that's how I would
present it
so your worship could we perhaps move on
the discussion by
actually moving no or I will be at this
stage yeah yeah I'm just gonna let
another couple of quick discussions
rangi I've got you Michael look going
back to the de Papa one again now no one
has spent more time and money than doing
a name than our Museum of New Zealand
they've separated the Terrell name and
the Museum of New Zealand by using a
different shade of font they've split it
up
um they've made it work and again I I
reiterate using the word of gives
ownership and now if you if you apply
the English language to it that's what
it means
Museum of Southland and if he's Southern
Museum
sorry I reckon it cheapens cheapens the
brand so I'm actually with Alex I
actually
um would have sooner this been brought
to us in imagery with options like like
something like that we would have gone
oh yeah Southern Museum something and
put together yeah like all these
different things and then we would have
chosen that
um
so anyway we're doing it this way but uh
this is important we get it right
because I tell you what this we're gonna
live with this and we only got one
chance
yep everyone followed by Michael
followed by Lee
Kilda um so
whilst I
my runaka suggested when we were asked
to import into the English version as
well as the Terrell Vision Museum of
Southern because it's out comfortably
with us I don't think that we're wanting
to dictate how The Branding goes if that
is the name that is chosen I think The
Branding will follow that's my opinion
um and as for
the how
[Music]
um
I mean
I remember when to Papa
national museum of New Zealand was open
with much flourish and ceremony well it
so quickly became just a papa that most
people don't actually remember that
tongariwa and I think it's got our place
as well
um you know
people liked the crispness
the imagery among a lot of people did
most people did
um
I think that our public is
well chose how they feel comfortable
using the name and the process but a lot
of it will depend on what follows after
this decision in terms of
how the marketing brand names which I'm
not really into but how that all follows
and we will have some input on to you
know our equivalent of the fingerprint
that will be where we get to say this is
what we prefer about this or this is
what we prefer about that and then if
that means that things are not quite
what we individually envisage that's not
really the point I'm not creative
digital artist or anything like that
as long as it's consistent with the
story that we are telling that will be
what people will look to and so for me I
encourage you because we don't get a
vote I encourage you to make a decision
um that
what her personal preference is is
irrelevant this is the decision for the
community and then we'll go with it and
support it even if it's not our personal
preference because that's democracy
just before I come to you Lee I guess
um
The Branding will be issue will be the
issue also speak with the national
museum opened
um I suspect The Branding wasn't
initially to Papa it evolved over time
and people now know it as to Papa and
don't know if there's anything else
including the wider name that that
Evelyn said which I've had a look at
recently
which is a bit more of a Time twister
and I think that'll happen with us as
well and to Rio name Will evolve over
time but as an interim step you still
want people to know it's a museum so um
you wanted to have some input
I think from the Project's point of view
sorry
yeah from the Project's point of view
obviously
um we needed uh a name we needed a name
to build our experience off to build our
branding off and to complement the
design work that the design team of so
done so well so for us it's about uh
Council making the decision on a name
and let us bring back branding options
and and how we display that name but we
need the first step which is a decision
on a name yeah and I guess just as a
reflection of that we've been a long
time getting this name by my assessment
at least nine months
um
and so it's important for us going
forward as certainly as we go to the
community funders which are not the not
the big stakeholders but the other
uh organizations around town that might
want us having that brand is going to be
really important
Michael for the final word thank you
through yourself in your Clark um look
I'd just like to highlight um especially
what Lee Lee's just um highlighted to
you as well is once we've got the name
then we can actually do The Branding we
couldn't do The Branding without a name
because it would have kind of been
pointless
um but having said that um also my
apologies in relation to putting the
dashes before the in the names it was
just to separate them sorry that is not
intended
um the dash it shouldn't be there almost
30 minutes they are one line
so our apologies on that front
um we will drop the dashes but that will
come through in The Branding from that
perspective thank you and the last one
is I just wanted to highlight that um
all four runaku and roonanga
um supported um option A in relation
relation either verbally or written
coming back back to myself
the very last one thank you your worship
so in the interests of the community and
having heard all the debate I would like
to move that we go through option for a
I just need we need to be cognizant of
that given they don't have a boat on
this issue yeah 100
all right 4A it is we'll come back some
of the other issues later on for you Lee
uh all those in favor
anybody opposed
Universe oh sorry Barry you are thank
you yeah it's like that recorded
counselors to it yep and I sat on the
fence so you abstain okay Peter
yep and the restaurant five only that's
nice can I just can I just jump in from
it just to reassure everyone because you
see so much passion around the branding
that would
timeline roughly for that Lee we're sort
of a little way away from there don't we
yeah look I think we need to get through
that next stage of design yeah and have
the concept of the experience brought on
board so I'd like to think that early
next year is probably an appropriate
time to be sort of put that you know
putting that work together yeah I think
if we try to do it this year we might
get it wrong yeah that's right we have
to have the experience evolved quite a
bit yeah
okay the floor's yours again Lee
second the floor's yours isn't it thank
you uh well first of all I'd like to
thank uh roel for making the trip and
helping out with this I'm gonna we're
leaving with his duties so he can catch
his plane
thank you
so unfortunately just left with us too
now
I would take the reporters
probably red and open the floor to
questions on
um size cost and anything else that
you'd like to talk to
um so I'll give you some info first
terms of that
um the size sits well within the bracket
that we gave initially if to open
attention for that six million dollars
up is is not an inappropriate amount
given
how long ago we costed this which for my
memories at least two years maybe longer
um and just for those who are listening
and from the public an increase in
budget does not mean an increase in
rates or potentially an increase in our
debt levels and Council either we have
other options available to us
ringy yeah I'd like to
um just move uh the remaining three
options
three
up there come on really only back five
minutes I've read it all yeah I think
it's very straightforward and I don't
think there's anyone in this room who
would be against that
all right let's go for it
anybody else want to have any input
before I put those motions no
no recommendations
okay a mover and a signal for the ones
with the exception of the name which
we've already done one two three
voluntary cancel a bond thank you all
those in favor I I carried you've
learned a lesson here Lee always come at
the end of the meeting well I have to
put it under the quality of the report
on a serious note that was really it was
really good I think it was an amazing
project team yeah
we've done the major live items
worship thank you Darren thank you
Leslie uh we are now heading to PE
yeah
um Mr Mayor we've been snapped we've
finished it again
can't read the screen behind us so we
need to give a summary of the reasons
why we're moving into it
where are they
um which is
all the minutes uh so there's the Mover
negotiations
we're going into public excluded to
receive the minutes of the PE session of
Great South joint shareholders position
of council later in July
decision of risk and insurance I think
July session of infrastructure one
August session of bluff community board
seven August session
well-being committee eight August 7
Minutes of the peaks of finance and
projects 15 August Great South and
Indian space op station of statement of
intent
in Great South 23 24 City Center
activation plan Great South
constitutional review said and Grace
funding request South and charitable
first at Trust
charitable Hospital funding request
and the reasons are under 40 weight 48
1A
section 72i for pretty much all of them
is that one to the minutes it is the
second excellent
I agree with what has just been stated
could you repeat that firstly
enter into public yeah thank you Mr
Mayor yep
is that before the live stream ends
Michael or after
um before right Mr Mia Michael here's a
comment well Michael it's a comment
before it closes
just
um just before we go into public exclude
just the um two great South ones that
were mentioned
um the reason that they're going into
public excluders confident commercial
confidentiality so we can have
discussions about the content within
those the documents themselves
for the statement of a tent are already
public that perspective it's just so we
can have discussions and a bulk of that
discussion will be released publicly
immediately following the meeting with
redactions and tenders to get that out
as soon as possible
thank you
okay
yeah we can end the live stream now
does he